THANK YOU
SIR SIR LABOR -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO CONVENE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE'RE GOING -- TO
START WITH THE CENTER REQUIRES
SP.
FIVE TWENTY THREE AND THEN WE'LL
CONTINUE TO HOPE AND BESEECH
OTHER MEMBERS.
TO APPEAR.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
CINEMA CHOIR [inaudible]
WHAT?
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE CHAIR
IN.
MADAM SENATOR VERY GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE AT SECURITY HUNTING
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU. FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK AND YOUR STAFF TEAMS
WORK ON THIS BILL -- IN I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT IS FOR A
STRONG DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON THE
VOTERS BELIEVE THAT THEIR BALLOT
COUNTS AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO BE
IN FRONT OF YOU ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE PEDIA IS WELL.
AS YOU MAY REMEMBER WE ARE IN
FRONT OF THIS DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR REQUIRING
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY
VOTERS.
OF MISMATCHING SIGNATURES AT
LEAST EIGHT DAYS PRIOR TO AN
ELECTION.
AND ALSO GIVE THE VOTER AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VERIFY THE
SIGNATURE.
WHAT WE KNEW LAST YEAR -- AND
THAT BILL BY THE WAY WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR IS IT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND BALLOTS
WERE TOSSED.
OUT BECAUSE OF A MISMATCH
SIGNATURE THIS YEAR WE'RE BACK
WITH A ECOND VOTER EMPOWERMENT
DALE PARTNERING WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
ON BALANCE THEY DON'T HAVE A
SIGNATURE INCLUDED.
IN THE GOLDEN STATE ROBERT HALF
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS NOW VOTE BY
MAIL BECAUSE OF THE MISSING
BALLOTS WERE REJECTED IN THE
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ELECTION.
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE IN
THIS MODERN DAY.
SIGNATURE ISSUES SUCH AS A
MISSING SIGNATURE IS ONE OF THE
TOP REASONS THAT VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS ARE REJECTED.
FOLKS MAY NOT KNOW THAT THEIR
SIGNATURES USED TO VERIFY THEIR
BALANCE.
IN THAT CREATES A PROBLEM UNIQUE
TO THOSE WHO VOTE BY MAIL.
SP FIVE TWENTY THREE REQUIRES
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY
VOTERS OF THE MISSING SIGNATURE
AT LEAST EIGHT DAYS PRIOR TO
CERTIFICATION OF AN ELECTION.
IN PROVIDE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VERIFY THE SINGER UP TO TWO
DAYS BEFORE THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE ELECTION.
THIS PROVIDES ADDITIONAL TIME
FOR VOTERS TO CORRECT A MISSING
SIGNATURE AND PROVIDES MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO COUNTIES TO
NOTIFY VOTERS.
AND THAT'S THE OTHER IMPORTANT
WORD IS NOTIFY RIGHT NOW WE'RE
NOT EVEN NOTIFYING THESE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOLKS THAT
THEIR BALLOT IS ABOUT TO BE
TOSSED.
TODAY OVER HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
BUT WHEN I MAILED IN SOME
COUNTIES CONDUCT ENTIRE
ELECTIONS BY MAIL.
AND THE USE OF VOTE BY MAIL BOWS
INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA WE MUST
ENSURE THAT ALL VOTERS HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY TO VERIFY THEIR
SIGNATURES.
MISTER CHAIR AT MADAME SENATOR I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
THE INCREDIBLE TIFFANY MOCK
SHE'S CHIEF OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS -- FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY STATE AS ONE TAKE MOM
SAY THINKING HIS MARK FOR HER
PARTNERSHIP AND WORK ON THIS
BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIFFANY MARK
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE
ALEX VIDEO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL AND THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE WE SIMPLY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
A MINOR MISTAKE LIKE FORGETTING
TO INCLUDE A SIGNATURE ON THE
BALLOT ENVELOPE SHOULD
DISENFRANCHISED VOTER. FOR THOSE
REASONS AND BECAUSE OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THIS PROCESS
PROVIDES OF REGISTRARS TO
CERTIFY ON ELECTION.
UP BY THE DATE THAT THEY
PREFERRED BUT STILL PROVIDES THE
VOTER THE ABILITY.
TO REMEDY THEIR MISSING
SIGNATURE WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
QUICK QUESTION OF MS MARKET IS
SEVEN REQUIRE INDUCE USE THE
INCREDIBLE TIFFANY MOCK IS
INCREDIBLE IS THAT A NICKNAME OR
IS THAT ACTUALLY YOUR GIVEN NME
IT WAS ACTUALLY A REFERENCE TO
HOW MANY COMMITTEES THAT I MUST
ATTEND WITH THE CENTER.
THIS MORNING.
IT'S ALL RIGHT IT IS QUANTIFIED
BY THREE COMMITTEES AT NINE
THIRTY ALL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WELL AN
AMAZING ARE I SEE THERE YOU GO
THAT'S THAT'S WHEN YOU HIT.
FOR OTHERS OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MY ANGER I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S ERIC KERRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
CARES AND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIM ALEXANDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VOTER FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT WILL GET A LETTER IN
SAN.
GOOD MORNING SMITH THE SAME NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
DORE ROSALIE ROOM VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS GONZALEZ CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
BUT THERE WE GO.
MORNING JOHN SOLVING YOUR
ACCOUNT A DO NOT SUPPORT.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS VERONICA
SOULS FROM YOU BUT COUNTY I DO
NOT SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THEIR STAFF TO TARA OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
I'M SORRY SIR SAID I'VE BEEN
HERE LESS PART AND CONTAINED
YEAH AND I'M ON A POLE I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CALLING BRITAIN I'M
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE OF OF COMMENTS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO PASS TALLER IF WE
GIVE IT TO SERGEANT.
AND IF I MAY READ THAT REAL
QUICK IT'S JUST SHORT -- SURE --
HOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA READ IT
OURSELVES HOW LONG IS IT?
IT'S ONLY ABOUT PAGE.
OKAY GO AHEAD OKAY.
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA OF OPPOSES SP FIVE
TWENTY THREE THE ELECTIONS VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOTS.
THE EXPANSION OF THE CANVASSING
TIMELINE FOR VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS PROPOSED AN SP.
FIVE TWENTY THREE IS UNNECESSARY
AND PROBLEMATIC AND WILL LIKELY
LEAD TO JUSTIN FRENCH MENTION ON
ANTENNA AND INTENDED FRAUDULENT
VOTING.
THE CURING PROCESS ALREADY IN
PLACE PROVIDES ADEQUATE
PROTECTION FOR VOTE BY MAIL
VOTERS THE LAW CURRENTLY
REQUIRES.
THAT VOTERS WHO FAIL TO SIGN
THEIR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS.
OR WHOSE SIGNATURES ON THE
ENVELOPE IS DEEMED TO BE A
MISMATCH BE NOTIFIED WITHIN
EIGHT DAYS.
ELECTION DAY AND GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VALIDATE OR
PROVIDE A SIGNATURE SO THAT
THEIR BALLOT CAN BE COUNTED.
SP FIVE THIRTY OF TWENTY THREE
EXPANDS THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THE REGISTERS HAVE TO NOTIFY
THOSE VOTERS.
UP TO INCLUDING EIGHT DAYS
BEFORE CERTIFICATION AND ALLOWS
THE VOTER RESPONSE TO ARRIVE
ANYTIME. TO AND INCLUDING IN
THEIR TWO DAYS PRIOR TO
CERTIFICATION.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN REGISTERS
FACE UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS FOR
BOTH VOTE BY MAIL AND
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS AND HAD TO
FIND POTENTIALLY.
EXTRA EXTRA LEGAL WAYS TO COPE
WITH THE NEW TIME LINES WHILE
STILL MEETING THE DICTATES OF A
FIX CERTIFICATION DATE.
SOME REGISTERS FELT FORCED TO
BEGIN PROCESSING PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS PRIOR TO THE COMPLETION
OF VOTE BY MAIL PROCESSING.
IN THE CASE OF A VOTER FOR WHOM
THERE WAS APPEARED TO BE BOTH A
VOTE BY MAIL.
AND A PROVISIONAL BALLOT CAST
THESE REGISTERS PROCEEDED.
UNDER THE PHILOSOPHY THAT IT
WOULD COUNT WHICHEVER BELL IT.
MADE IT THROUGH THE SYSTEM FIRST.
THIS VERSION OF THE LEGALLY
PRESCRIBED PROCESS INTRODUCED
THE POTENTIAL OF COUNTING A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
IN LIEU OF A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
AND THUS INCREASE THE
POSSIBILITY.
THAT A BALLOT NOT CAST FOR THE
LEGITIMATE VOTER COULD BE THE
ONE COUNTED.
FURTHER EXPANSION OF THE VOTE BY
MAIL PROCESSING TIME LINE MAKES
DEMANDS TO WHICH THE SYSTEM
CANNOT PROPERLY ADAPT.
AND VOTERS ARE LIKELY TO BE
DISENFRANCHISED.
AND VOTE FRAUD A BE FACILITATED.
THE P. I. C. C. A. APPLAUSE
EVERY EFFORT TO ENSURE.
THAT THE VOTES OF ALL ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS BE ACCURATELY
COUNTED.
HOWEVER WE CAUTION THE
LEGISLATURE AGAINST.
PRECIPITOUS MOVES THAT ARE BOTH
UNNECESSARY AND POTENTIALLY
DAMAGING MORE IS NOT ALWAYS
BETTER.
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST MORE.
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA URGES AND NO ON SP.
FIVE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GWEN MYERS OUT FROM
ROSEVILLE AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THE ELEVENTH.
NO QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
SIR MCGUIRE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS EMPOWERING VOTERS.
ARE JUST LIKE KITTENS AND APPLE
PIE.
EVERYONE LIKES IT.
AND EVERYONE.
WE HAVE A CRISIS IN THIS STATE.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
DID NOT HAVE THEIR VOTES COUNTED
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
LIBERTARIANS GREEN PARTY MEMBERS
INCLINED TO STATES.
AND WHY ANYONE WOULD BE HERE
TODAY ARGUING AGAINST COUNTY
BALANCE I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS CLEAR -- THIS BILL
IS ALSO UNDER THE AUSPICES OF A
B. EIGHT FORTY WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT RT ALLOWS
THE VOTERS DID NOT SIGN THEIR
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT TO RETURN.
A COMPLETED UNSIGNED BALLOT
STATEMENT BY EMAIL AND IT DOES
NOT CHANGE THE DISCRETION IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE DISCRETION OF
THE REGISTER VOTER REFERRING
MISMATCHING SIGNATURE THAT THEY
BELIEVE WAS FRIED GENTLY SIGNED
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
THOSE GLAD THOSE LAWS OF ART IN
PASSING THE STATE -- AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE NO
MATTER WHAT PARTY YOU BELONG TO
SHOULD BE ON RECORD TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY VOTE COUNTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
THOUGHT IT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SIR REQUIRE IT IF YOU
SEE -- SENATORS HERTZBERG OR
STERN AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS A NUMBER OF COMMITTEES THAT
ARE GOING ON AT THE SAME TIME IF
ONE OF THEM WOULD APPEAR THEN WE
COULD FORM A QUORUM AND WILL.
PICK UP YOUR MEASURE FOR VOTE SO
WE'RE GONNA BE ON THE HUNT.
HEY THERE YOU GO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR THING --
I SEE SENATOR ALAN HERE.
CENTER ELLEN -- AT YOUR SP SIX
SIX FOUR IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND THEN OF I WOULD.
JUST LIKE TO TAKE UP AS B. FORTY
SEVEN FIRST.
YES ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND WHEN I'M OBVIOUSLY
THINK THE I. THE DILIGENCE STAFF
WHO I KNOW AND LOVE WELL FROM MY
TIME AS CHAIR OF THIS WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE -- FOR THEIR WORK IN
HELPING TO PREPARE THE ANALYSIS.
THIS IS A BILL THAT -- FOLKS ME
RECALL -- FROM LAST YEAR WE'RE
FINALLY GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO LANDING THIS PLANE AND
I I'M JUST EXCITED ABOUT THAT
AND WE WERE.
THE THE THE STARS ARE ALIGNING
SO THIS BILL REQUIRES SIGNATURE
GATHERS TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS.
WITH THE NAMES OF THE TOP THREE
FOUNDERS OF AN INITIATIVE
CAMPAIGN FOLKS MAY REMEMBER THE
DISCLOSE ACT WE DID A FEW YEARS
AGO -- WHERE WE REQUIRED THE TOP
THREE DONORS TO INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES TO BE DISCLOSED ON
TV ADS IN ON MAILER SO THAT WHEN
YOU GOT A MAILER FROM?
CALIFORNIANS FOR MOM AND APPLE
PIE YOU KNEW ACTUALLY HE WAS
PAYING FOR THE THE CAMPAIGN WELL
SIMILARLY WHEN SOMEONE STANDING
OUTSIDE THE MARKET AND YOU KNOW
I'M FROM SANTA MONICA RIGHT WE
WERE GOING TO MARKET TRYING TO
GET SOME FARRO OR KEEN WHY SINCE
FAT -- OR LENTILS YOU KNOW THE
FOUR FOOD GROUPS OF SANTA MONICA.
AND JUST YOU KNOW JUST BE ABLE
TO GET GET YOURSELF A LITTLE
FOOD NO QUAL KALE CUTS FIVE FOOD
GROUPS AS YOUR TAIL.
AND IF SOMEONE THROWS A AS GOOD
POSITION IN FRONT OF YOU AND
SAYS THIS IS GONNA SAY WESTERN
CIVILIZATION AS YOU KNOW IT.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO'S
PAYING FOR IT HALF THE TIME THEY
KNOW THEY'RE GETTING FIVE BUCKS
A SIGNATURE.
AND SO THEY'RE GONNA DO WHATEVER
IT TAKES TO GET YOU TO SIGN SO
WE OUGHT TO HAVE A SYSTEM.
WHERE THE WHERE THE VOTER HAS TO
BUILD A HAS TO BE DISCLOSED
INFORMATION HAS TO BE DISCLOSED
TO THE THE SIGNATORY SO THAT
THEY HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHO IS?
BEHIND THE THEIR SIGNATURE
COLLECTION DRIVE.
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
CURRENCY.
ARE WE HAVING MORE AND MORE
INITIATIVES ON THE BALLOT.
AND AND AND A LOT OF OF
GAMESMANSHIP THAT HAPPENS TO
GETTING PEOPLE SIGNATURES.
SO DID THEM THE GOOD NEWS IS
THIS IS ACTUALLY THIS DISCLOSURE
ISSUE SOMETHING THAT ATTRACTS
FOLKS FROM ALL ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM I TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN YOU KNOW
LITERALLY ALL OVER YOU YOU BOTH
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS
INDEPENDENTS OVERWHELMINGLY.
SUPPORTED INCREASED DISCLOSURE
SO I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I HAVE TRAVELING HERE
WITH ME IS PRESENT EXACTED
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAN'T IT'S A MAJOR
PRIORITY OF THEIRS AND NICHOLAS
TYRANT WHO IS A POLICY LEGAL
DIRECTOR.
OF CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
ANOTHER IMPORTANT PARTY FOR OF
THEIRS AND THEY'RE GONNA BE HERE
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IS A SUPPORT?
AT MY PRESENT CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN VERY HAPPY TO BE
HERE WE ARE THRILLED THAT
SENATOR ALLEN IS TAKEN UP THIS
VERY IMPORTANT EXPANSION OF THE
DISCLOSE ACT AGAIN.
AS AS HAS HE SAID I THINK THAT
WE ARE.
WE'VE HONED IN ON A SOLUTION
THAT REALLY WORKS LAST YEAR
PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
POSSIBLY HAVING.
TO REPRINT PETITIONS WHEN THE
TOP FUNDER IT'S CHANGED -- THIS
SOLUTION USING THE OFFICIAL TOP
FUNDERS SHEET THAT ANY PETITION
GATHER CAN PRINT OUT AT HOME
EASILY AND LASTS FOR FOR A MONTH.
I THINK ADDRESSES THOSE THOSE
PROBLEMS SO -- AS HE SAID IT HAS
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT -- ARE
CLEAN MONEY ACTIVISTS HAVE BEEN
OUT IN FORCE AT AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT RALLIES IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE RALLIES
AND THINGS HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
THEY'VE ALREADY GATHERED -- OVER
TEN THOUSAND SIGNATURES -- BY
PAPER IN OUT IN THE FIELD OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND OVER ALSO I
THINK THAT SHOWS THE THE BROAD
INTEREST IN THIS AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CHARMERS MEMBERS NICKELS HEAD ON
WITH CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
WE'RE PLEASE BEEN STRONG
SUPPORTERS DISPOSE WELL.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LEADING
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO CAMPAIGN
FINANCE DISCLOSURE WE ALSO
HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF THE LEADING
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO JUST
PEOPLE QUALIFYING INITIATIVES
WE REALLY THINK THIS BILL HELPS
TOO BECAUSE THOSE TWO WORLDS
INTERSECTED WITH WILL REALLY
HELP THE VOTERS HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S COMING
IN FRONT OF THEM.
WE THINK THAT TOO WILL LEAD TO
AN IMPROVED QUALITY IN THE
INITIAL VISIT TO QUALIFY FOR THE
BALLOT.
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WERE
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SO IF YOU WOULD -- I SEE YOU'VE
GOT QUITE A NUMBER OF FOLKS HERE --
GOOD FOR US.
SO IF YOU WOULD GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION -- I
ASSUME SINCE YOU'RE IN THE
SUPPORT LINE YOU SUPPORT AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD SOMETHING TO
WHAT THE WITNESS IS ALREADY SAID --
FEEL FREE TO ADD SOMETHING.
YOUR ROSE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
EVERYTHING'S BEEN SAID WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CALIFORNIA NICHOLAS GONZALEZ FOR
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WE ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIABLE TRANSPARENCY --
KELLEHER'S CAMPAIGN AND WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SHANE MCLEOD REPRESENTING MONEY
OUT VOTRS IN AND I'M A FORMER
CAMPAIGN MANAGER OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN INITIATIVE CALLED VOTERS
RIGHT TO KNOW PLEASE SUPPORT.
SUNSHINE IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT -- LINE -- INTO
APPARENT RETIRED EDUCATOR UP
FROM BASS LAKE CALIFORNIA --
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU.
BILL WALTER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT BECAUSE THREE FUNDERS.
HI HOWARD MATTER SOME FROM
OAKLAND IN CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY I SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
A SURELY SHOWING US THE PLEASANT
HILL AND I'M ALSO EASTBAY
COORDINATOR OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY.
AND ONE OF THIS PETITION GATHERS
AND PEOPLE ARE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS MEASURE SO PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
CAT WITH CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
AND I SUPPORT TRANSPARENT
DEMOCRACY PLEASE SUPPORT THE
PETITION DISCLOSE ACT.
THANK YOU.
NANCY NOW FROM PALO ALTO AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU.
THE FIRST BE RETIRED PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR FOR IN THEM.
PAT LANG LOS ALTOS HILLS PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH LUNDGRENAND
ALL I'M A VOTER FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW CALIFORNIA AND I ASK.
THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CAROL CONCERN FROM
OAK GROVE CALIFORNIA RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AREA AND I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
YOU.
CITY WHEREVER I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE'S THERE'S AN FROM JAIL RYE
THANK YOU PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
CAROL BADGER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
RESPECTIVELY.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING JACQUELYN DOER FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATE AND A VOLUNTEER FOR
CLEAN MONEY AND I URGE TO
SUPPORT RED TO SUPPORT SB.
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
OF RUBBER CALL THE CLEAN MONEY
SUPPORTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DAVE JAKE UPS ON THE
SECOND ON A RESIDENT -- I AM --
REPRESENTING -- REPRESENT US
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND I REALLY
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU YOUR HI CRAIG
DUNKERLEY FROM SAN JOSE I ALSO
SERVE ON THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
A CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMISSION
ON ELECTIONS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF SIR YOU MAY CLOSE --
I'M SORRY YOU SAID EARLIER --
HIM QUIETLY SITTING OVER HERE --
I JUST WANT TO SAY I LOVE THE
BILL LAST YEAR I LOVE THE BILL
THIS YEAR I THINK THAT OUR
SIGNATURE GATHERING HAS REALLY
GOTTEN PERVERTED OVER THE YEARS.
AND FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW PEOPLE
ALWAYS ASK HOW DO I KNOW WHO'S
TELLING THE TRUTH AND A LOT OF
TIMES I THINK ALL PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW WHO IS SUPPORTING SOMETHING.
AND THEN YOU CAN MAKE A BETTER
DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WANT TO SIGN THE PETITION SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING BACK IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR LABOR OUT
INCORPORATE BY REFERENCE YOUR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
SO.
SO -- I KNOW THERE'S A QUITE A
NUMBER OF FOLKS HERE WHO ARE
INTERESTED THIS BILL -- WE CAN'T
TAKE IT UP FOR VOTE UNTIL WE
HAVE A QUORUM AS I MENTIONED A
LITTLE WHILE AGO THERE ARE
SEVERAL COMMITTEES ARE ALL
MEETING AT THE SAME TIME IT'S
JUST.
WHAT HAPPENS HERE -- AND SO --
WHEN WE HAVE ANOTHER SENATOR
APPEAR WILL FORM A QUORUM AND
THEN -- MOST LIKELY TAKE THE
BILL UP FOR VOTE.
IS AROUND TO DO WHEN I CLOSE I'D
INCORPORATE BY REFERENCE THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES I I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS AND AND I I
ALSO WANT TO DIS DIED SEND A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE OTHER
ACTIVISTS WHO'VE BEEN WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS.
ISSUE FOR SO LONG AND IT'S THERE.
IF THEIR ENERGY AND THEIR
RELENTLESSNESS IN THE CONTINUING
TO PUSH FOR TRANSPARENCY THAT
ARE THAT THAT THAT I THINK IS
HELPING TO MAKE OUR DEMOCRACY A
LITTLE BIT BETTER.
IN THESE WILD TIMES AND SO THANK
YOU.
TO THE COMMON CAUSE WITH WOMEN
VOTERS AND MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
AND AND CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN AND
REPRESENT US ALL THE DIFFERENT
GROUPS THAT ARE WORKING SO HARD
ON THIS.
THANK YOU SIR WELL DON' GO
ANYWHERE.
YES.
WHAT'S RIGHT.
MY FAVORITE COMMITTEE RIGHT
[inaudible]
YES OKAY.
FANTASTIC.
OKAY SO THIS IS ANOTHER SO
EFFECT SOME OF THE FOLKS ARE
STAYING HERE -- BECAUSE IT'S
ANOTHER REFORM BILL IN THIS
RELATES TO ANOTHER PROBLEM WITH
OUR DEMOCRACY THAT IS THE
PROBLEM OF GERRYMANDERING -- AND
THE FACT THAT.
WE HAVE DONE AWAY WITH
POLITICIANS DRAWING THEIR OWN
DISTRICT LINES AT THE STATE
LEVEL BUT THE PHENOMENON STILL
EXIST -- IN MANY LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AND LET LET ME JUST
SAY THIS IS ITEM FOR FOR THOSE
OF YOU WITH YOUR PLAY BOOKS OUT
THERE -- IN ITS S. B..
ONE THIRTY NINE SO I'D LIKE TO
OBVIOUSLY THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE COUNTIES WITH MORE THAN.
TWO FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS. TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION
ENSURING A MORE FAIR.
NON PARTISAN SYSTEM FOR DRAWING
THE LINES OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICTS.
SO FOLKS MAY REMEMBER THAT WITH
PROPER LEVIN BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WE CREATE THE
CITIZENS REDUCTION COMMISSION
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW
WE HAVE INDEPENDENT -- DISTRICT
LINE DRAWING HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF OUR
DISTRICT LINES WERE DRAWN UP.
BY -- THE INDEPENDENT ADJUSTER
COMMISSIONS.
AND THERE'S BEEN A REAL
INTERESTING TRYING TO EXPAND
THIS THIS PRACTICE TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE HAD S. B. ELEVEN
AWAIT TWENTY SIXTEEN US BEST BE.
TEN EIGHTEEN BOTH MY BILLS TEN
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT
AUTHORIZED COUNTIES -- AS CITIES
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO ESTABLISH --
REGISTERED IN COMMISSIONS.
AND NOW COURSE THOSE LAWS ARE
PERMISSIVE IN THE JURISDICTIONS
CAN CHOOSE WHETHER TO ADOPT.
THOSE REGISTERED COMMISSIONS IF
THEY WANT OR OR A MAYBE THE
CITIZENS CAN ALSO.
PUSH FOR SOMETHING LIKE THAT ON
THE BALLOT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
JERRY MANNER HAS CONTINUED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU SEE THAT IN
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS I
MEAN BY.
ONE ANALYSIS I SAW RECENTLY FROM
THE LEGO I REPORTED THAT -- YOU
KNOW.
THAT LATINOS ARE 40% OF STATE
BUT ONLY 10% OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS -- BEANO OFTENTIMES
YOU'LL HAVE COUNTIES WHERE --
THE COUNTY MAY BE VERY
POLITICALLY DIVERSE BUT THE
BOARD IS DOMINATED BY ONE
POLITICAL PARTY.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE ONE PARTY OR
THE OTHER HAS DOMINATED THE THE
THE DRAWING OF THE LINES AND WE
ALL KNOW FROM OUR STUDY OF
NATIONAL EXAMPLES HOW.
THE EXTREMES TO WHICH MEMBERS OF
BOTH PARTIES HAVE BEEN WILLING
TO TAKE GERRYMANDERING TO
MAXIMIZE PARTISAN ADVANTAGE.
THE STATE LEGISLATURES ALREADY
PASSED BILLS TO REQUIRE LA AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTIES TO ADOPT
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH COMMISSIONS.
AND IT'S NOW OUR STRONG SENSE
THAT IS THE TIME FOR EVERY FOR
THE OTHER LARGE COUNTIES TO JOIN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN
CONGRESS AND TAKE.
PART IS IN AT A SELF INTERESTED
POLITICAL GERRYMANDERING OUT.
OF REDISTRICTING.
SO I THOUGHT THAT'S AFFECTED
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT REQUIRES
OF THE INDEPENDENT REGISTERED
COMMISSION WILL HAVE THE FULL
POWER TO DRAFT.
AND ADOPT MAPS INDEPENDENT OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION MEMBERS
BE POLITICALLY INDEPENDENT AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME IT PROHIBITS
PARTISAN GERRYMANDERING COUNTY
REDISTRICTING.
IT ENSURES TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THAT DROP MAPS THE
PUBLISHED FOR SEVEN DAYS BEFORE
ADOPTION AND THAT THE COMMISSION
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC BY HOLDING AT
LEAST THREE PUBLIC HEARINGS
PRIOR TO ADOPTING ANY MAPS.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
I HAD WITH THE CHAIR AND AND I
KNOW THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
AND AND WE REALLY ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING -- TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THE YOUR YOUR CONCERNS AND AND
AND INTERESTS ARE MET IN IN IN
REALLY TRULY ENSURING THAT THIS
IS THIS IS A TRUE FAIR AND
INDEPENDENT PROCESS.
AND IF THIS BILL DOES MOVE FOR
TODAY I AM ONE OF THE PRISON
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND WITH THE CHAIR. TO
ENSURE THAT -- THAT THE GOALS OF
THIS COMMITTEE ARE ARE DRESSED
IN AND WHATEVER FIND OUT COME.
IS IN THIS BILL SO WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE -- SEVERAL FOLKS WHO
BROKEN INTRODUCES US A NECKLACE
FIRST FROM -- COME TO US.
KAREN BERG NICHOLAS I DON'T WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE WE'RE
VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR SP ONE
THIRTY NINE TO ENSURE A FAIR AND
INDEPENDENT COUNTY REDUCING
PROCESS. FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST COUNTIES.
MENTORING HAS NO PLACE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AT ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN INCUMBENTS ABUSE LINE
DRAWING PROCESS TO ADVANCE OUR
OWN PERSONAL AND POLITICAL SELF
INTEREST?
IT HARMS PUBLIC TRUST IN THE
FAIRNESS OF OUR PROCESS.
UNDERMINES THE REPRESENT OF
NATURE OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND DEPRIVES THE VOTERS.
OF THEIR ABILITY TO HOLD THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WHEN IT COMES
TO STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S DONE MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE TO
ELIMINATE GERRYMANDERING.
CALIFORNIA STATE CITIZEN
REDUCING COMMISSION WHICH
REMOVES INCUMBENCY BIAS FROM THE
PROCESS IS CONSIDERED THE
NATIONAL GOLD STANDARD BY MANY
ACADEMICS AND REFORM
ORGANIZATIONS.
BAD NEWS HOWEVER IS THAT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL WERE INCUMBENTS
CONTINUE TO CONTROL THE PROCESS.
RACIALLY DISCRIMINATORY PARTISAN
AND PRONE COMING GERRYMANDERING
PROCESS.
REGISTERING ABUSE CONTRIBUTES TO
THE UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
RACIAL MINORITIES IN COUNTY
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS AMONG THE
LEAST REPRESENTED LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA XANDER
MENTIONED CORN TO TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LATEST STUDY.
OF 40% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
LATINO BUT ONLY 10% OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS ARE IN FACT JUST
LAST YEAR.
NOW THE PHONE A SUIT AGAINST
KERN COUNTY.
SHOWING THAT IT HAD VIOLATED THE
FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT TO
SOME FRANCHISING THEIR LATINO
COMMUNITY.
BUT THAT'S NOT JUST NICELY THAN
INSTANCE SIMILAR ALLEGATIONS BY
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS A
MINORITY DISENFRANCHISEMENT
OCCURRED LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
ORANGE COUNTY SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY INTO OUR ACCOUNT IS JUST
TO NAME A FEW.
REDUCING WE ALSO KNOWS USED TO
ABUSE TO DISENFRANCHISE VOTERS
JUST BASED ON THEIR PARTY
AFFILIATION -- IN MANY COUNTIES
A PARTY AFFILIATION OF A
MAJORITY OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STARKLY AT ODDS WITH
OTHER ELECTORATE IS VOTING. TO
GIVE ONE EXAMPLE FROM YOUR
COUNTY IN ORANGE COUNTY GOP
CONSULTANTS ACTUALLY WENT TO
EVERY SINGLE SUPERVISOR.
AND TOLD THEM TO BASE THEIR
REDISTRICTING ON PARTY
REGISTRATION FIGURES AND WHEN
THE FINAL MASTER ADOPTED.
THEY WENT TO THE PRESS IN
OAKLAND OPENLY SAY IT STATED
THAT THEY WERE HAPPY THAT THEY'D
GUARANTEE THAT QUOTE WITH THOSE
LINES.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WILL
CONTINUE TO OF ALL REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS FOR THE NEXT DECADE.
I WANT TO STRESS HOWEVER THE
REDUCING IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
WHEN DEMOCRATS IN POWER THEY TO
CONFUSE PROCESS --
GERRYMANDERING IS SIMPLY NOT
LEFT FOR SAYS RIGHT IT'S ABOUT
THE UNFAIRNESS OF THOSE WHO ARE
IN POWER ABUSING THE PROCESS TO
TRAIN SOME CELLS FROM
COMPETITION.
THAT'S REASON WHY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AS P. ONE THIRTY NINE IT
EXTENDS A VERY SUCCESSFUL STATE
MODELS IN PENRY DISTINCT TO OUR
LARGEST COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
IT ENTERS A FAIR TRANSPARENT
PROCESS BY FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
COMMISSIONERS.
WINNING IN DUST -- INPUT OF
REDUCING IS A FAUCET IS FIRMLY
TAKEN ROOT IN CALIFORNIA WITHIN
NOW'S THE TIME TO EXTEND IT TO
THEIR COUNTIES FOR THOSE REASONS.
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
INTERACTION I VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO.
THIS ISN'T MY OKAY HI SORRY
ARCHER -- BERG MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MONICA
BROWN AND I'M A SOLANO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
I STRONGLY URGE APPROVAL OF
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY NINE
BECAUSE I HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND
HOW THE REDISTRICTING PROCESS
CAN BE ABUSED FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
MY STORY CONFER CONCERNS FORMER
SUPERVISOR BARBER CAN DEALERS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BARBER
RAN FOR A SEAT ON THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SHE LOST.
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REDISTRICTING TOOK PLACE AND HER
HOME WAS PURPOSEFULLY REMOVED
FROM DISTRICT ONE THE BOUNDARY
WAS MOVED AND WENT AROUND HER
HOME.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO SHE RAN
AGAIN IN DISTRICT ONE AFTER
MOVING OUT OF HER HOUSE TO A
DUPLEX ONE MILE AWAY.
SHE WON THE INCUMBENT CHOSE NOT
TO RUN.
SHE WON AGAIN IN 962-000-2000
FOUR IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TODAY
HER ORIGINAL RESIDENT IS BACK IN
DISTRICT.
ONE WHEN I INTRODUCED
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING DONE
SOLANO COUNTY I COULD NOT GET A
MAJORITY OF THE SUPERVISORS TO
SUPPORT IT.
THE RATIONALE WAS SUPERVISORS DO
NOT WANT TO GIVE UP THEIR
AUTHORITY.
THOSE WHO BENEFIT THE MOST FROM
DISTRICT LINE SHOULD NOT BE
TASKED WITH DETERMINING THOSE
LINES.
I URGE APPROVAL OF SENATE BILL
[inaudible]
ONE THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
SURE I REMEMBER.
UP I'M DOOR ROSE I AM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH LEGAL MOVE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA HERE TO SUPPORT
AND CO SPONSOR.
S. B. ONE THIRTY NINE THE LEAGUE --
WAS IN A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
BRINGING AN INDEPENDENT RIGID
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION TO
CALIFORNIA OUR LOCAL LEAGUES ARE
A BIG PART OF THE MOVEMENT TO
BRING INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING.
TWO COUNTIES AND CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION THEY'RE REALLY IN
THE TRENCHES TRYING TO GET THE
JOB DONE RIGHT.
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THE
COMMISSIONERS REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE.
IN WHICH REDISTRICTING IS
OCCURRING.
WORKING TO HELP DRAW THE MAPS
AND PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANTLY
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THAT OCCURS
IS REALLY ROBUST.
THAT IS MEANINGFUL AND THAT IT'S
DIVERSE.
SO IS.
THERE IS -- BEHIND ME -- IS.
THERE.
ONE AND THE REASON FOR ALL OF
THIS RESOURCE SO INVESTED IN
THIS IS THAT WHEN A LEGISLATIVE
BODY DRAWS ITS OWN LINES THERE
IS NECESSARILY A TEMPTATION. TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT EITHER --
HURTS OR HELPS INCUMBENTS OR
POTENTIAL MEMBERS OF OF THE BODY
ITSELF.
WAR TO PRESERVE POLITICAL PARTY
IN IT APPLE POLITICAL POWER IN
ONE POLITICAL PARTY.
THESE ARE NOT ABSTRACT CONCERNS
YOU'VE HEARD A FEW OF THE HORROR
STORIES IN THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY WE REALLY THINK IT'S
TIME TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP.
THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP IN THIS IS
TO REQUIRE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS IN --
IT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SPECIFICALLY IN LARGE COUNTIES
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND POPULATIONS -- BEFORE
COUNTY SUPERVISORS STREET IS S.
C. SET THAT IS A GOOD START TO
SORT OF MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD -- VOTERS WANT TO KNOW.
THAT THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ELECT PEOPLE WHO REALLY
REPRESENT OUR COMMUNITY'S
INTERESTS THEY WANNA KNOW.
THAT ELECTIONS ARE CLEAN THAT
THEY'RE FAIR AND THIS IS A BIG
PART OF THAT.
AS AS TO WHAT WE'RE MAJORITY
MINORITY STATE AND AS NICHOLAS
TESTIFIED -- THE GIVEN THE GREAT
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE.
IS WOEFULLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
THE COUNTY SUPERVISORS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
BY FIXING THE WAY THAT WE DRAW
THESE -- LOCAL LINES BUT BY
TAKING THAT NEXT STEP.
WE'RE GOING TO GO A LONG WAY I
BELIEVE IT'S A IN THE PROCESS OF
BECOMING A MORE TRULY
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
WHICH IS REALLY THE KEY.
AND SO WE HOPE THAT.
YOU ILL TAKE THIS NEXT STEP
WITH US AND THAT YOU WILL --
VOTE TO PASS SB ONE THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WOULD AS WE MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO IDENTIFY YOURSELF
WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
IF YOU'RE PART OF AN
ORGANIZATION OR REPRESENTING
ORGANIZATION THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
AND IF YOU LIKE TO ADD TO THE
ELOQUENT TESTIMONY ALREADY
RECEIVED FEEL FREE TO DO SO.
I AM NICHOLAS GONZALEZ OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCACY
THERE IS A REASON WHY CALIFORNIA
IS BEING PRAISED BY ITS REFERS
DISTRICTING REGULATIONS I THINK
WE SHOULD EXPAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI AM EVAN MINTON I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOICES FOR PROGRESS
WE GALVANIZE THE ADVOCACY OF
BUSINESS LEADERS ENTREPRENEURS
FULLY AT THEIR PRESENT OTHER
PROMINENT INDIVIDUALS.
TO UNITE TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT STRENGTH IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND INSURE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE FOR ALL.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY NINE IS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY BILL FOR
DEMOCRACY BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS.
BELIEVE IT GERRYMANDERING IS A
SERIOUS THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY
THE MAST.
BE RECTIFIED AND LIKELY
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION TO WORK FOR THEIR
THEIR POPULAR WITH VOTERS WITH
THE APP CAN MEAN. TWENTY TEN
TWENTY CENSUS TAKING PLACE WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THAT THIS IS
THE RIGHT TIME TO PASS THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BELL AND WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
PLAYING CALLOUSED COVER CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN WE NORMALLY FOCUS
ON CAMPAIGN FINANCE REFORM
ISSUES BUT WHEN THE DISTRICTS
AREN'T FAIR YOU DON'T HAVE FAIR
ELECTIONS SO WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU AND
YOU.
SHANE MCLEOD OF SACRAMENTO
PLEASE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THERE LATER
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT -- CENTER.
CENTER THE CENTER ISLAND I I
JOIN WITH ALL THOSE WHO --
APPLAUD YOU FOR DEALING WAS
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- AND THANK YOU
ALSO FOR OUR CONVERSATIONS
CONCERNING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK ARE OF CONCERN YOU
KNOW WANT ONE ISSUE.
IS.
WHILE WE WE I THINK THE MAJORITY
OF US CERTAINLY SUPPORT
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CODIFY SOMETHING.
THAT.
THAT STILL TIES THE THE PROCESS
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN STATE LAW
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A FIVE FIVE
SPLIT AT LEAST INITIALLY IN THE
IN THE FIRST GO ROUND THE STATE
INDEPENDENT.
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS THAT
DOESN'T REFLECT THE THE PARTISAN
DIVIDE NOW IN THE STATE.
AND SO -- I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOU
TO COMMITTING TO WORKING WITH US
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE HAVE
SOME SORT OF PROPORTIONALITY
WITH RESPECT TO THE ULTIMATE.
DECISION MAKING BODY WITH
RESPECT -- TO THE LINES.
SO -- HAVING SAID THAT -- WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOTHES I JUST
REITERATE MOMENT INTERESTING
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE IN WITH YOU ON ON THIS
BILL THIS MOVIE FOR THINKING
THAT THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND AND CAN AGREE
WITH.
TRVELING MORE I MEAN THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING THE WHOLE SYSTEM
FAIR AND AND WHEN THIS
MANIPULATION THE PROCESS IT.
IT -- IT DESTROYS TRUST IN
DEMOCRACY FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU.
SO AS I MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF YOU HERE
THERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
THAT WE WILL TAKE THE BILL UP
FOR VOTE AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE IS THAT THERE ARE NUMBER
OF COMMITTEES MEETING SO.
SIR ALAN WHEN YOU SEE THE
SENATORS STERNER HERTZBERG IF IF
THEY'RE NOT ACTIVELY ENGAGE THE
COMMITTEE -- IF YOU'D ASKED THEM
TO JOIN US THAT WOULD BE GREAT
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE HOT NOW.
YES THANK YOU -- I SEE -- SIR
MORLOCK IS HERE CENTER
[inaudible]
THANKS.
THANK YOU MS OWNER SO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SP.
FIVE ELEVEN I TOO AM ENJOYING A
FUN.
MORNING BY SECURING TWO
COMMITTEES AT OUR MEETING AT THE
SAME TIME SO I MORNING.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR
CENTER LABOR -- I WANT TO
DISCUSS SENATE BILL FIVE ELEVEN
THE DMV VOTER REGISTRATION
TRANSPARENCY IN TRAINING.
OUR COLLEAGUES A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO DURING THE BREAK -- IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I CAME UP TO
THE CAPITAL AND I SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT WITH -- OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX PADILLA
IN HIS OFFICE -- I HAD BEEN
GETTING LOTS OF REQUESTS FROM
CONSTITUENTS WILL THIS MOTOR
VOTER BILL WHEN IT IS
IMPLEMENTED IN AN APRIL WILL IT.
WILL BE A LOT A LOT THE LET ME
JUST INTERRUPT YOU FOR A SECOND
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS HERE ALL MY
WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND THEN I'LL GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE WORLD FAMOUS SENATOR
HURTS THE FAMOUS SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS HERE YES.
MAJORITY LEADER.
NONETHELESS SO.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLE FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
NUMBER YOUR NUMBER HERE NIELSEN
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
LABOR.
LABOR HERE STERN.
CAN WE HAVE A RIGHT THANK YOU WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO.
IT DID TAKE A POSITIVE BY A WEEK.
THAT'S WHAT SERGEANTS ARE ABOUT
SORRY.
THAT ARE MORE LIKE I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE ONE OF HIS
PRESENTATIONS I BUY COMMITTED AS
WE WANT TO CAPTURE QUARREL SO.
I'M SORRY THANK YOU NUMBER IT'S
NINE MISTER CHAIR -- YOU'RE
SAYING YOU KILL TO SEE SENATOR I
CAME UP AND I MET WITH SECRETRY
OF STATE -- ALEX PADILLA AND I I
SAID I'M GETTING ALL KINDS OF
EMAILS AND CALLS AND QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF MOTOR
VOTER WILL IT BE SAFE AND SECURE
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT.
OUT ONLY THE ARE ARE ARE
APPROPRIATE PEOPLE REGISTER FOR
THE VOTE.
AND I WAS GIVEN A NICE ASSURANCE
AND LECTURE ON HOW SAFEGUARDS
WERE IN PLACE -- IN IT AND WE
KNEW THAT THERE WERE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DMV'S UNPREPAREDNESS
EVEN AT THE TIME THAT THE BILL
TO IMPLEMENT WAS DEBATED.
ESPECIALLY ON THE I. T.
COMPONENT OF THE WHOLE
TRANSACTION SO HERE WE ARE --
FOUR FIVE SIX MONTHS LATER IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
WE LEARNED OF A DMV INTERNAL
AUDIT SHOWING THAT.
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED CUSTOMERS
THEIR TERMS MAY HAVE BEEN
IMPROPERLY REGISTERED TO VOTE.
SO I WROTE A FOLLOW UP LETTER TO
MISTER VIDEO FOR AN EXPLANATION
REGARDING SOME TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND A RONI IS VOTER
REGISTRATIONS.
PORTED TO HIS OFFICE I AND I
SENT THAT IN SEPTEMBER.
THE CALLING I'M SOMEONE WHO
OBTAINED THE PRIVILEGE TO VOTE
THE OLD OLD FASHIONED WAY THE
HARD WAY I HAD TO EARN IT I HAD
TO APPLY FOR CITIZENSHIP.
AND THEREFORE THAT.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE IS VERY
SACRED TO ME PERSONALLY.
CONSEQUENTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE MY CONCERNS. FOR THE
AUDIT RESULTS WITH REMEDIES SP
FIVE ELEVEN RECOMMENDS
ESTABLISHING A COMMITTEE TO
FACILITATE THE BETTER SHARING.
OF INFORMATION WITH REGARDS TO
MOTOR VOTER.
I HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTRAR VOTER
VOTERS SAID NEIL KELLY WHO
YOU'RE WELL AWARE MISTER CHAIR.
IS A CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL I
ENJOYED WORKING WITH HIM AS A
FELLOW DEPARTMENT HEAD AND THEN
AS HIS BOSS WHEN I WAS HIS BOSS
HAS.
WHEN I WAS A SUPERVISOR?
AND HE'S JUST DIE WELL RESPECTED
IN THE FIELD AND FIVE ELEVEN IS
THE RESULT OF OUR COLLABORATION
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS A DARK
SHADOW HANGING OVER CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTION PROCESS.
LET'S GET THE PARTIES TOGETHER
DISCONTINUE THE BLAME GAMES AND
FOCUS ON PREVENTING FUTURE
ERRORS IN ORDER TO RESTORE VOTER
CONFIDENCE IN THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS AND THIS I BELIEVE
IS A PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO
MANAGE THROUGH THE SITUATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU AND I ASSUME YOU'RE
AWARE OF SENATE OXES ME --
REGISTRAR KELLY'S LETTER THAT HE
SENT TO THE COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE JUST SENT TO THE END
YEAH RIGHT ALL RIGHT AND YOU AND
IT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO THINK YES
SO MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT MR
CHART.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERIC HARRIS ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE ELEVEN FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST DISABILITY RIGHTS
GROUP IN THE NATION WE WORK TO
PROTECT AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
OUR MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE
EDUCATE INVESTIGATE AND LITIGATE.
TO ADVANCE THE RIGHTS DIGNITY
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES AND CHOICES
FOR ALL PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
VOTING ACCESS IS ONE OF THE MAIN
PRIORITIES FOR DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WORK SO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
CAN VOTE PRIVATELY AND
INDEPENDENTLY.
OUR VOTING RIGHTS.
UNIT.
PROVIDES OUTREACH IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY WITH VOTING
RIGHTS VOTING RIGHTS AND CIVIC
PARTICIPATION TRAININGS.
THE R. C. IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
REQUIRING ESTABLISHMENT OF A
COMMITTEE.
AS SPECIFIED AND SUPPORTS THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL TO ENSURE
THAT THE THAT THE DMV EMPLOYEES
ARE TRAINED ON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM.
YES ON THE EXPERIENCES OF DRC
CONSTITUENTS.
WHO ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES?
THE R. C. BELIEVES THAT PRIOR
DMV STAFF TRAININGS HAVE BEEN
LESS THAN ADEQUATE.
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENT IS
CRUCIAL FOR THE RC WE BELIEVE
THAT SPECIFIC TRAINING FOR ALL
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND ALL.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE LANGUAGE FOR THIS BILL
IMPACTS AS MANY PEOPLE
POSITIVELY AS POSSIBLE -- AND WE
PLEASE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE LABOR CENTER HERTZBERG.
NO.
SO -- I'VE GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS -- SO THE SO A CENTER
MORE LIKE -- I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL BUT I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE THE
COMMITTEE WHO WHO'S GOING TO
FORM THIS COMMITTEE WHO'S GONNA
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR FORM THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR IT IS.
A LITTLE VAGUE BUT IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE PARTIES
TOGETHER SECRETARY OF STATE THE
DMV THE REGISTER VOTERS -- ARE
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
TO HEAD TO WORK TOGETHER AND I I
THINK THEY COULD SELL SELECT ON
WHO WOULD CHAIR AND WHO WOULD
GET THE AGENDA MOVING.
ALL UP I SUPPORT THE CONCEPT I
AM CONCERNED IF WE DON'T DEFINE
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE TO ORGANIZE
THIS AND ORGANIZE THE COMMITTEE
THAT JUST WON'T EVER GET
ORGANIZED.
SO IMPRESSIVE SECTORS THEY WILL
DO IT -- BUT A SUGGESTION TO YOU
IS IS THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
DESIGNATE A ORGANIZING ENTITY.
FOR THE COMMITTEE -- IN IN TERMS
OF THE THE PRODUCT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF PRODUCT -- AND I REALIZE
THAT YOU WANT TO PRE JUDGE THE
THE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
MAYBE YOU DO -- BUT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF PRODUCT DO YOU EXPECTING
OR HOPING FOR WELL WE WANT TO
HAVE. ZERO ZERO ZERO RATE OF
ERRORS BUT WE WANTED.
TRAIN.
BUT DO YOU WANT THE COMMITTEE
WILL MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
COMMITTEE WILL SUGGEST
LEGISLATION WHAT WHAT.
WELL IF WE CAN JUST PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE INTERNAL -- ONE
TRAINING -- TO IMPROVEMENT OF
THE SOFTWARE.
IT'S BEEN QUITE QUITE
INTERESTING TO LISTEN TO
CONSTITUENTS TALK ABOUT WHEN
THEY RE WRITE THEY THEY REACH UP
THEIR DMV RENEWAL AND FIND THESE
FIVE QUESTIONS AND ON THE ON THE
WEBSITE THEY JUST DON'T SEEM.
TO INTEGRATOR CONNECT WE GOT A
LEASE START IMPROVING THE
SOFTWARE SYSTEM THAT'LL ALLOWS
PEOPLE.
TO RENEW THEIR DMV WITHOUT
HAVING THAT AWKWARD SITUATION
WITH THE REGISTRATION FOR VOTING.
SO I I WOULD SAY THAT IF WE
COULD GET THOSE TWO AREAS
CORRECTED -- THAT WOULD BE THE
GOAL OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO GOAL NUMBER ONE TRADING DMB
EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE
[inaudible]
T THIS'LL TAKE.
WHATEVER WE WANT WITH THE WITH
MOTOR VOTER AND THEN GOAL NUMBER
TWO IS. TO IMPROVE THE SOFTWARE.
AND IF IT IF YOU WANT ME TO PUT
AMENDMENTS IN THE GET THAT
CLARIFIED I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT.
WELL.
MY MY CONCERN IS I OR EXPRESS
FIRST CONCERN IS THAT WE
DESIGNATE SOME ENTITY OR AS THE
CONVENING.
AUTHORITY IF YOU WILL.
AND THEN SECONDLY IS IT THAT WE
PROVIDE SOME GUIDANCE AS TO WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SO THAT WE
DEFINE THE SCOPE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
IN A WAY THAT THE THEY DID WITH
THE THEY PRODUCE FOR US.
SOMETHING THAT IS OPERATIONAL
[inaudible]
GOOD.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU ASSUME YOU WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
IS IT IS THE FILM'S FORD ALL
RIGHT.
OKAY -- ANYTHING ELSE BASED ON
WHAT I'VE ASKED.
NOTHING OKAY CENTER HERTZBERG
HAS MOVED -- WE'RE IN A
FORTUNATE POSITION OUT OF
ACTUALLY TAKE A VOTE SO BUT OF
SECRETARY -- I'M SORRY SIR MORE
LIKE YOU LOOK CLOSELY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CALLING SO I AM NOT.
AN ADVOCATE OF ESTABLISHING
COMMITTEES THIS IS NOT USUALLY
WHAT I DO MISTER CHAIR -- BUT AS
A LEGISLATOR LOOKING TO AVOID
OUR STATE RECEIVING ANOTHER
BLACK EYE THIS APPEARS TO BE AN
APPROPRIATE FIRST STEP.
IN THE MANAGEMENT PROCESS. TO
ASSURE GOOD GOVERNMENT POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THE DMV HAS NOT
BEEN GARNERING GOOD PRESS OF
LATE LET'S PROVIDE A WORKABLE
SOLUTION TO IMPROVE THE
SITUATION I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE ON SP.
FIVE ELEVEN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR -- SECRETARY MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE NUMBER NINE NUMBER GUY
NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG PRESSBURG BY LABOR.
LABOR I STERN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE THE WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ARMS ALL RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU CENTER MORE LOCK UP.
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
BUT NONE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO WE CAN NOT WHAT WE DO THIS
WHEN WE TAKE A VOTE ON OTHER
OTHER MEASURES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY PENDING.
SO WE HAVE SP FIVE TWENTY THREE%
BY CENTER MCGUIRE.
MADAM SECRETARY.
WE NEED YES THAT'S GOOD IDEA --
THOROUGHLY INFLATABLES.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AMBERG
HI AMBER I NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG HERZBERG I IT LABOR.
LABOR I STERN.
ALL RIGHTS AND FOR ALL THESE
REALLY KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
SOME TIME -- SENATOR ALAN.
FIRST LET'S START WITH THIS BE.
FORTY SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SEND THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
NUMBER HI I'M BERG I NEIL SEND.
HURTS BIRD HERZBERG I ELEVEN
LEAVE US I STERN.
RIGHT NEXT IS CENTER ELLIS SP
ONE THIRTY NINE CONCERNING
REDISTRICTING WE NEED A MOTION.
SENSOR LEVEL MOST.
MOTION IS TWO PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE --
BURKE HI NUMBER I NIELSEN
HERTZBERG.
SPRING I LABEL.
LABOR I STERN.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE NEED
EMOTIONAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
CENTERS FOR MOST.
HI MADAM SECRETARY FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AMBERG HI
NUMBER I NIELSEN HERTZBERG.
CHRIS BURKE I LABOR LABOR I
STERN.
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE ARE WAITING.
FOR SENATOR STERN -- AND I I'LL
GO AHEAD AND DO MY BILLS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING SENATOR STERN --
LABEL OKAY SO CENTER HERTZBERG --
GO.
BUT THEY'RE IN NEED OF AMENDING
RIGHT [inaudible]
THE US.
OKAY -- BUT NEVER TO THIS IS --
YOU WANT TO START CENTER WITH
FILING A NUMBER THREE SP SEVENTY
TWO CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION PROVISIONAL BALLOTS
.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SERVICE CENTER
HERTZBERG -- LAST YEAR MARKED
THE FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA AS
OF VERSION OF THE SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION WAS AVAILABLE. FOR
STATEWIDE ELECTIONS.
LAW REQUIRES THESE VOTERS
COMPLETE AFFIDAVIT OF
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
AND CAST A PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS TABULATED
ONLY HALF THE REGISTRATIONS
CHECKED FOR VALIDITY AGAINST THE
SO SECURITY AND DMV RECORDS.
THE STATEWIDE VOTER DATABASE TO
INSURE THE VOTER DID NOT ALREADY
RECEIVE A BALLOT ELSEWHERE.
IN SOME WAYS THE SYSTEM WORKED
WELL FOR INSTANCE OVER FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SAME DAY BALLOTS
WERE CAST IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION ALONE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE REPORTS
THAT THERE WERE NO LET ME
UNDERLINE THAT NO REPORT
INSTANCES OF FRAUD ASSOCIATED
WITH.
THEM ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
THE GLARING PROBLEM HOWEVER WAS
THAT SAME DAY VOTER VOTING
SIMPLY WASN'T OFFERED IN NEARLY
ENOUGH LOCATIONS.
CURRENT LAW ONLY REQUIRES THAT
IT BE OFFERED THE PERMANENT
OFFICES OF THE COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND AT BOTH CENTERS IN
THE COUNTIES PARTICIPATING IN
THE VOTER'S CHOICE ACT.
ONLY FIVE NON VOTERS CHOICE AT
COUNTIES CHOSE TO OFFER SAME DAY
REGISTRATION.
AND VOTING AWAY FROM THEIR
PERMIT OFFICES AS A RESULT.
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS WERE FORCED
TO WAIT HOURS LONG LINES IN
ORDER TO PARTICIPATE OR SIMPLY
DID NOT PARTICIPATE.
WHILE THERE WERE NO MORE OF
THERE WILL BE NO MORE -- BOATER
CHOICE -- BACK CANDIES IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXCUSE ME STRIKE
THAT WELL THERE WILL BE MORE.
THE C. A. R. VOTER CHOICE AT
COUNTIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS WILL RESIDE
IN A NON.
VCA COUNTY REQUIRING ELIGIBLE
VOTERS TO TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES
AND WAIT IN LONG LINES.
IS UNACCEPTABLE THE SOLUTION IS
SIMPLE.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
AS BE SEVENTY TO REQUIRE ALL NON
VC COUNTIES TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION AT
EVERY POLLING PLACE THERE BY THE
FILLING IS TRUE.
POTENTIAL THE GOVERNMENT'S
COUNTIES TO CHOOSE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WHETHER THEY WANT TO GO HI TECH
WITH ELECTRONIC PULL BOOKS.
INVALID ON DEMAND PRINTING
SYSTEMS OR LOW TECH BY SIMPLY
PROVIDING THE SAME DAY VOTER.
THAN OLD FASHIONED PAPER
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
BOTH WILL GET THE JOB DONE S. B.
SEVENTY TWO IS SPONSORED BY THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS COMMON
CAUSE ACLU AND SUPPORTED BY
NUMEROUS OTHER GROUPS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHEN THIS IS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THE CANADIAN -- PROMISES SOME
HAVE THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST THREE YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S ROLLED OUT A NUMBER
OF REFORMS MEANT TO MAKE VOTING
AND REGISTRATION I'M MORE
ACCESSIBLE MOST NOTABLY
AUTOMATIC AGE A LOT MORE THAN
EIGHT YEARS WITH THE LAST WELL
IN PARTICULAR THINGS HAVE REALLY
PICKED UP.
SPEED OVER THE LAST.
LAST FOUR YEARS I THINK BUT I'M.
BUT I'M HIGHLY AUTOMATIC
REGISTRATION IN THE BUSH CHOICE
ACT.
WE AND AND BUT DESPITE THESE
WERE FOR REFORMS IN NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE SAW A FIVE
AND A HALF MILLION UNREGISTERED
ELIGIBLE VOTERS.
AND TWELVE AND A HALF MILLION
ELIGIBLE VOTERS DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE ELECTION.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT REGISTRATION
AND PARTICIPATION GAPS.
CONTINUE TO EXIST IN FACT
ACCORDING TO RECENT RESEARCH
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PROJECT PARTICIPATION
GAP BETWEEN LATINO VOTERS AND
NON LATINO OR ASIAN VOTERS.
WAS HIGHER IN TWO THOUSAND IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
GENERAL ELECTION THAN IT HAS
BEEN SINCE. TWO THOUSAND TEN
LAST YEAR WE'RE EXCITED HAVE
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
ROLLED OUT FOR THE FIRST TIME
STATEWIDE IN A GENERAL ELECTION.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE COMPLAINT
IMPORTANT ROLE IN HELPING TO
CLOSE THESE PARTICIPATION GAPS.
HOWEVER COUNTIES.
WE'RE ONLY REQUIRED TO OFFER CD
ARE AT THEIR MAIN OFFICE WITH
THE OPTION OF OF OFFERING
ADDITIONAL SITES AND AS WE HEARD.
I'M ONLYFIVE COUNTIES
ULTIMATELY OFFERED MORE THAN A
SINGLE SITE ON ELECTION DAY DO
YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JUST A CURIOSITY BECAUSE
IT WAS A TWO HOUR DRIVE I
INTRODUCED A SAME DAY
REGISTRATION BILL TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
AND THE GOVERNOR THE TIME WAS
WORRIED THAT WHAT HAPPENED IN
MINNESOTA THAT YOU'D HAVE SIX
ELECTIONS ON THE SAME DATE OF
WILD OUTCOMES AND SO WE
COMPROMISED FIFTEEN DAYS.
WHICH RESULT IN SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE VOTING IN
THE NEXT LOS ANGELES CITY
ELECTION.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WITH
RESPECT TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU GOT DROPPED
IN NORWALK TO VOTE ON THE SAME
DAY.
THAT UNDER THE FEAR BILL DID YOU
DID YOU DID YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
WHAT THE VOTE COUNT WAS THERE TO
SCARE THE FED ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND CONDITIONAL BUTTER AT
MANY BOATS AND WELL JUST PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
SACRAMENTO HAD.
YOU KNOW.
I THINK CLOSE -- TO TEN THOUSAND
CONDITIONAL REGISTRATION BALLOTS
CAST HERE WHERE CD R. WAS WIDELY
AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE A LOT FEWER VOTERS IN
LOS ANGELES I'M NOT SURE IF HE'S
OBVIOUSLY I KNOW BUT I THINK IT
DOES SPEAK TO WHERE IF YOU OFFER
MORE SITES WITH MORE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS TOLD US IN TESTIMONY IN
VARIOUS HEARINGS THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS.
HE COULDN'T GET IT DONE BUT YOU
FOR OF CONFIDENCE THAT THEY CAN
I MEAN I I WAS THAT I DON'T CARE
GET A NEW JOB.
TONS OF THE MORE IMPORTANT
VOTING BUT THIS IS GREAT I LOVE
IT.
YEAH I MEAN AND SO.
ANYTHING AS AT THE CENTER
EXPLAINABLE PART OF WHY I THINK
WE THINK.
ALL COUNTIES CAN'T GET THIS DONE
IS THAT THEY HAVE THIS LOW TECH
OPTION OF OFFERING A PROVISIONAL
BALLOT -- FOR THE TYPE OF THE
TYPE ABOUT THAT'S OFFERED AT
EVERY POLLING SITE THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED THESE HIGHER
TECH SOLUTIONS OF THE POLL BOOKS
WERE.
BAD ON ON DEMAND IF THEY HAVE
THAT THAT'S FANTASTIC AND THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM TO USE IT.
ON THE COST OF ALSO DIRECT
VOTERS TO THE CORRECT PULLING
SIDE IF.
I'M.
GIVE THAT WATER THAT OPTION BUT
IF THE VOTER.
FIRST ABOUT THEIR THEY CAN VOTE
AT AT THE SITE WHERE THEY ARE
JUST LIKE.
ANY REGISTERED VOTER CAN YOU CAN
SHOP AT AT THE POLLING SIDE OF
YOUR CHOICE AND IF YOU CAN.
IF YOU WANT ME ONE TWO THREE
AWESOME PROVISIONALLY DATA.
THAT INTERRELATE.
IN THE COUNTIES WHERE WE HAD
MORE LIKE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THERE WERE CERTAIN COUNTIES IN
SP. FOR FARMER FOR FOUR FIFTY
YEAH THAT WE DO WITH WHAT I DO
WITH BEN ALLEN THAT WE DID WE
HAD VOTES CENTERS JUST A
CURIOSITY GEMINI IN A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.%
THE SAME DAY REGISTRATION VOTERS
VOTERS ALLOWED TEN DAYS VOTING
WHICH IS A BIG DEAL IN THE THE
POINT IS CERTAINLY REMOVE EVERY
BARRIER HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO GIVE
EVERYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO IN A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO ND
COUNTIES THAT ADOPTED BOTH.
WE'RE A PUT UP TO DEFEAT THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT ALL ALL OF
THEM HELD HIGHER CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION IS OAKS
CONDITION MOTOR CHECHEN WAS
REQUIRED ALL OF THE VOTES ENTERS.
INTO WHAT WE SAW THERE WHERE
THEY HAD MUCH HIGHER RATE OF
USAGE.
I'M WHEN YOU'RE OFFERED
EVERYWHERE.
IN THE VOTERS WERE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF HIGHER RATES
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
I SO WE THINK THERE'S SOME THE
MAN JUST ONE OR THE OTHER THING
TO POINT OUT THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO PUT IT WE WE RECENTLY GOT
SOME DATA FROM.
I'M ACTUALLY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
SHARED SOME DATA WITH US.
IT SHOWED THAT THERE WERE FIFTY
THOUSAND VOTERS.
I'M IN NOVEMBER WHO -- SHOWED UP
AT A POLLING SITE THEY WERE THEY
VOTED PROVISIONALLY AND THEIR
VOTES WEREN'T COUNTED BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T REGISTERED TO VOTE
UNDER THIS BILL WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO COUNT THOSE VOTES.
I'M I KNOW THERE'S THERE'S BEEN
SOME AND CONCERNS RAISED OVER
WELL.
WE'RE GOING TO VOTERS WHO -- IF
THEY'RE NOT AT THE CRACK PULLING
SITE UNDER THIS UNDER THIS
METHOD OF GIVING THEM THE BALLOT.
AVAILABLE AT THAT AT THAT
POLLING SITE THEY WOULD HAVE.
I'M.
THEY WOULD NECESSARILY GET TO
VOTE ON EVERY ELECTION.
AND SINCE THERE'D BE SOME DOWN
BALLOT RACES AND AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
BUT ON THE OTHER I WOULD
EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT THERE THERE
IS THERE WAS NO FRAUD THE SECTOR
EXCEEDS -- OFFICE FOUND.
NO REPORTED INSTANCE OF FRAUD
AND BUILT INTO OUR SYSTEM OF C.
B. R. IS PROTECTIONS.
EVERY VOTER CAST A PROVISIONAL
BALLOT -- UNDER THE SECRETARY
STATE REGULATIONS THEY CAN
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS HAVE TO
PROCESS THE REGISTRATION FIRST
MATRIX PROCESSES SUCCESSFULLY
AND THEN VEER VERIFY THAT THE
VOTER HASN'T VOTED IN ANY OTHER
COUNTY WE HAVE A STATEWIDE VOTER
DATABASE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO DO
THIS NOW.
AND SO WE HAVE BUILT IN
PROTECTIONS IN TRYING TO POSSESS
IT IS.
SENATOR UMBERG I WOULD BE SO
HONORED IF YOU'D LET ME JOIN
YOUR BILL IS AS A CO AUTHORS
WHATEVER WE CHOOSE I'D LIKE --
TO TO JOIN IN ON THIS EVER IT'S
GREAT TAKE THE REVISED.
SO.
AND WE'LL ADJOURN THIS MEETING --
GONE THERE IS A NEIGHBOR EVA
VIRGIN I THANK YOU OKAY QUESTION
OTHER WITNESSES.
YES.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS OSCAR COPELAND I'M A
FOURTH YEAR SENIOR IDC BERKELEY.
AND SETTING POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND CAMPING COORDINATOR FOR
CALPERS NEW VOTERS PROJECT -- I
BELIEVE THAT VOTING IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO TO PREVENT PROVE OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND BELIEVE THAT'S
GREAT THERE'S GREAT POWER THAT
COMES WITH BEING INFORMED AND
EDUCATED VOTER.
I'M THE NEW VOTERS PROJECT IS A
CAMPAIGN THAT WORKS ON RAISING
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT ON OUR CAMPUSES
AND COMMUNITIES AROUND US BY
REGISTERING NEW VOTERS RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF VOTING.
AND PROVIDING TOOLS AND
RESOURCES FOR THOSE THAT NEED IT --
TO BECOME MORE EDUCATED AND
INFORMED VOTERS DURING THE LAST
MID TERM ELECTIONS WE WERE TO
REGISTER OVER SIX THOUSAND NEW
STUDENT VOTERS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND MADE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GET OUT THE VOTE
EFFORTS LEADING UP TO THE MID
TERM ELECTION.
THESE ARE SOME EXCITING
SUCCESSES FOR SURE BUT THERE ARE
MANY VERY BARRIERS IN PLACE FOR
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR ELECTION --
THERE PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY CANNOT
KEEP UP WITH THE REGISTRATION
DEADLINES AS THEIR JUGGLING
OTHER PRIORITIES IN LIFE SUCH AS
SCHOOL.
FAMILY I'M WORKING JOBS --
DURING THE MID TERM ELECTIONS
ARE MANY STUDENTS THAT CAME UP
TO US AND TOLD US THAT THEY
MISSED THE DEADLINE TO REGISTER --
AND SPLITS THE WANTED TO CAST
THEIR VOTE THE ONLY UP.
A CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
SITE IN ALAMEDA COUNTIES IN
OAKLYN WHICH CAN BE A TWENTY
MINUTE DRIVE FOR STUDENTS --
MANY STUDENTS DON'T HAVE CARS ON
CAMPUS SO ON THIS IS REALLY A
BARRIER KEEPING STUDENTS FROM
CASTING THEIR VOTE ON ELECTION
DAY -- STUDENTS AT UCLA I
ACTUALLY HAD TO TRAVEL TO OUR
NEARLY TWO HOURS TO GET TO THE
CLOSEST CONDITIONAL LETTER TO
READ VOTER REGISTRATION SITE.
I'M ONLY CONDITION ONLY
SITUATION SITE DISCOUNTING.
BY THE WAY A LITTLE OF THAT
HISTORY.
NO NO.
NO.
WE CERTAINLY NEED EVERYBODY TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON ELECTION DAY
AND KNOW THAT INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF POLLING PLACES THAT
OFFER SAME AY VOTER
REGISTRATION WOULD REMOVE MANY
OF THE BARRIERS THAT FACE VOTERS
TODAY.
SB SEVENTY TWO PASSING WOULD
PROVIDETHE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY POTENTIAL
VOTER HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON ELECTION DAY.
THIS WOULD EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND REINVIGORATE OUR
DEMOCRACY THAT WORKS BEST WHEN
EVERY PERSON IS ABLE TO HAVE A
VOICE IN IT.
I AND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY STUDENT
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
SIGNED ON TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND FULLY SUPPORT ON THE BILL
THOMAS.
THANK YOU HEATHER WITH DECISION
SUPPORT.
YOUR ROSE THE WORD VOTERS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL AND I ALSO WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT DUE TO A RECENT
COURT SETTLEMENT.
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA REGISTRARS TO PURGE
INACTIVE VOTERS FROM THE ROLLS.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
FAIL SAFE BECAUSE AN INACTIVE
VOTER WHO HAS BEEN PURGE WILL BE
ABLE TO SHOW UP AT THEIR POLLING
PLACE.
AND TO REGISTER AND VOTE AT THE
SAME TIME SO E DO NOT END UP
LOSING THOSE FOLKS VOTES.
THANK YOU SO VERY.
MUCH.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I DON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMING BECAUSE WE SIMPLY DON'T
THINK REGISTRATION SHOULD BE A
BARRIER TO VOTING WE NEED TO
MAKE IT EASY ACCESSIBLE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS GONZALEZ FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPPOSITION.
WHO WANTS TO LEAVE THE UP YOU
CAN SET UP HERE?
HI MY NAME IS CALLING BRITAIN
I'M WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
HE'S SENDING OUT A POSITION
PAPER THAT I DON'T BELIEVE YOU
HAVE RECEIVED YET BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
IT.
AND I'D LIKE TO READ IS REAL
SHORT SO -- DIRECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA OPPOSES SP
SEVENTY TWO CONVERSION
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
AND PROVISIONAL BALLOTS.
MUST BE SEVENTY TWO AS WELL
INTENTIONED BUT AN INTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCES OF ITS IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTATION.
WHAT HE WROTE THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY IN VOTER CONFIDENCE
PHILIP LEGITIMATE VOTERS WOULD
BE UNDERMINED?
UNLAWFUL VOTERS WOULD BE CAST.
COUNTED.
OF EACH PIECE A PIECE THE I. P.
C. A. APPLAUDS EVERY EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT ALL ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS BE AFFORDED A PATH
TO REGISTERING TO VOTE.
AND TO VOTING AS UNIMPEDED AS
POSSIBLE HOWEVER ARE EIGHT YEARS
PLUS OF EXTENSIVE RESEARCH AND
DOCUMENTATION.
REQUIRE THAT WE RECOMMEND
EXTINCT EXTREME CAUTION WITH
RESPECT TO THE TENANTS OF S. B..
SEVENTY TWO THOUSANDS OF
INCIDENT REPORTS SIGNED UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY BY THOROUGHLY
TRAINED.
OBSERVERS SHOW THAT REGARDLESS
OF THE QUALITY OF TRAINING
SUPERVISION NETWORK SOME POLL
WORKERS WILL FAIL TO ADHERE TO
CORRECT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS THE
HONEST ERROR ENACTED IN ADEQUATE
ADEQUATE TRAINING.
IN ATTENTION DURING TRAINING
UNWILLINGNESS TO REVIEW OR REFER
TO THE PROVIDED REFERENCE
MATERIALS UNWILLINGNESS TO ADOPT
NEW LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
SAYING THIS IS THE WAY I'VE
ALWAYS DONE IT THIS IS I'M NOT
GOING TO CHANGE NOW.
AND EVEN HAVING A PERSONAL
AGENDA THE I. P. C. A.'S
COMMUNICATION NETWORK WITH
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS.
HAS BEEN HELPFUL AND WERE A
RECTIFYING MANY OF THOSE
IRREGULARITIES AS THEY OCCUR.
THERE IS MUCH MORE PROGRESS THAT
NEEDS TO BE MADE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF ELECTION INTEGRITY AND VOTER
CONFIDENCE.
THE CURRENT JOB OF A POLL WORKER
IS DEMANDING AND EXHAUSTING
EXPECTING THOUSANDS OF POLL
WORKERS TO ADD TO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES THE PROPER
REGISTRATION AND THEN PROPER
PROCESSING OF NEW VOTERS.
WITH CONSISTENT CORRECTNESS
ESPECIALLY UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
OF HIGH DEMAND AND POTENTIALLY
LONG LINES OF INPATIENT
INDIVIDUALS.
IS A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
THE I. P. C. H. DOCUMENTATION
SHOWS THAT MISTAKES.
SUCH AS THOSE IN ENUMERATED IN
PREVIOUS PARAGRAPH ARE VERY
COMMON.
MAKING THE JOB OF POLL WORKERS
EVEN MORE COMPLEX AND EXPECTING
ACCEPTABLE INTEGRITY IS NAIVE AT
THE BEST.
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN ELECTION
SAME DAY REGISTRATIONS
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATIONS
WAS LIMITED BY LAW TO THE
REGISTER'S OFFICE.
AND SATELLITE OFFICES INCLUDING
VOTE CENTERS NEVERTHELESS EVEN
AND IN COUNTIES WHERE POLL
WORKERS TRAINING WAS IMPECCABLE.
THE I. P. C. A. OBSERVERS
DOCUMENTED NEIGHBORHOOD PRECINCT
POLL WORKERS REGISTERING VOTERS
UNLAWFULLY AND ISSUING
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS THAT THE LAW
WOULD UP BY LAW WOULD NOT BE
COUNTED.
THUS DEPRIVING THOSE VOTERS.
OF THEIR FRANCHISE.
THEY HAVE BEEN PROPERLY DIRECTED
IN ONE OF LITTLE LAWFUL CV ARE
LOCATIONS -- HAD THEY BEEN
DIRECTED TO ONE OF THE LAWFUL
CVR LOCATIONS THEIR VOTE WOULD
HAVE COUNTED.
EVEN MORE EGREGIOUS YET IS THAT
OBSERVERS DOCUMENTED
NEIGHBORHOOD PRECINCT POLL
WORKERS SAME DAY REGISTERING
VOTERS AND ISSUING POLL BALLOTS.
THOSE BALLOTS COULD NOT BE
RECALLED OR CANCELED SHOULD THE
REGISTRATION BE REJECTED.
AN UNFORGIVABLE BALL
UNFORGIVABLE BLOW TO ELECTION
INTEGRITY AND TO EVERY PERSON
WHO VOTED LAWFULLY.
CLEARLY THE CHALLENGES OF PROPER
ELECTION MANAGEMENT ARE ALREADY
MONUMENTAL.
LIVING CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION TO LOCAL POLLING
SITES WILL GUARANTEE SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBERS.
OF VOTES WILL BE MISHANDLED.
EVERY MISHANDLED VOTE DILUTES OR
CANCELS OUT THE VOTE OF A
LEGITIMATE VOTER.
EVEN ONE OCCURRENCE IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
IN VOTING LOCATIONS CURRENTLY
TASKED WITH CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION WORKERS ARE BETTER
TRAINED AND BETTER SUPERVISED
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO MATERIALS
AND BALANCE NEEDED. TO CORRECTLY
AND ACCURATELY PROCESS EACH
VOTER THEY SHOULD REMAIN THE
ONLY LOCATIONS TO OFFER SAME DAY
RED.
RED SAME DAY SERVICES.
IN ADDITION S. B. SEVENTY TO
CREATE INEQUALITY OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR VOTERS FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY
AND COUNTIES WHERE ELECTRONIC
PULL BOOKS.
AND ALL BELT STYLES ARE ABLE TO
BE CALLED UP AND ALL LOCATIONS.
NEW REGISTRANTS WOULD BE PER.
THUS ENABLING THEM TO ACCESS ALL
CONTEST WITHIN THEIR THAT
JURISDICTION.
NEW REGISTRATIONS AND COUNTIES
NOT YET EQUIPPED WITH POLL TECH
PROPER TECHNOLOGY WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE DO WITH SINGLE BALLOT STYLE
OFFERED BY THAT PRECINCT.
IN WHICH THEY ARE REGISTERING BE
AT THEIR OWN ARE NOT.
THOSE VOTERS REGISTERING OUT OF
PRECINCT WOULD THEN BE
DISENFRANCHISED WITH RESPECT TO
SOME CONTENT CONTEST NOT
REFLECTED ON APPLE'S BALLOT.
IN THE LATER CASE FURTHER BURDEN
WOULD BE PLACED ON THE COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICE DURING THE
BALLOT PROCESSING.
AS REDUCTION OR DUPLICATION
WOULD BE NECESSARY.
CURRENTLY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION ARM AREA.
AND EVEN WITHIN ELEVEN DAYS OF
ELECTION UNREGISTERED
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ARE WELL SERVED UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA URGES A NO VOTE ON S.
B..
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION BRIEFLY.
YEAH HOW YOU DOING JOHN SULLIVAN
I'M OFTEN OFFICES.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE IN ON FUMES
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS NOW I
FEEL I SPEAK FOR SIXTY THREE
MILLION VOTERS OUT THERE THAT.
HAVE BEEN DELEGITIMIZE AND
HAVEN'T HAD A VOICE AND THE
STATE THAT I I AM A NATIVE.
TO THE CARPET CLEANING INDUSTRY
FROM OAKLAND TO SACRAMETO IS
AND AND IT DID IT WITH ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
AND I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW I I
HEAR IN THIS ROOM AS OUR FORM OF
DEMOCRACY AND APPARENTLY NOBODY
OWNS A CONSTITUTION.
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION FOR THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO HAVE A REPUBLICAN FORMER
GOVERNMENT IN THE STATE.
SO -- I JUST WANTED TO BE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS AS WELL
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST GONNA
FURTHER.
DELEGITIMIZE THE AMERICAN VOTER
THE CALIFORNIA VOTER IN -- I
WOULD THINK WITH ALL THE STATES
THAT ARE SPLITTING -- UNDER THE
LAST.
PRESIDENCY THAT -- MAYBE YOU
GUYS WOULD.
WAKE UP TO THIS THAT'S ALL I'M
GONNA SAY I KNOW I'M JUST ONE
MAN BUT I'M GETTING BACK ON MY
FEET AGAIN.
AND I'M IN MY FIFTIES I LIVE
WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
FOUR YEARS WHEN I HAD IT FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS BECAUSE I WAS
LIVING ON FUMES BECAUSE YOU LIVE
LANTERNS FOR AUTHOR DOING MY
WORK FOR ME RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU COMING
[inaudible]
NEXT.
MY NAME STAND NEAR THE CAR SOME
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
COULD I JUST SAY JUST A FEW
WORDS PLEASE [inaudible]
HOW?
LOT OF PEOPLE I'VE TALKED TO
OVER THE LAST FEW ELECTIONS.
SEEM TO BE GETTING VERY
EXTREMELY UPSET THE SAY LEAST.
HEY I'M NOT I THINK IT REALLY
HIT HOME WHEN I WAS TALKING TO
MY WIFE THE OTHER DAY SHE PLAYS
A LARGE GROUP OF CARDS WITH
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE MIXED BAG.
SOME OF THEM DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
THE DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN OR WHAT
THEY ARE. ONE THING THAT SHE DID
SAY THEY GOT A LONG CONVERSATION
THERE IN A CARD GAME.
TALKING ABOUT THE BOAT
HARVESTING TALKING ABOUT KIDS
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD BEING ALLOWED
TO VOTE TALKING ABOUT.
WASHINGTON.
STATE OR WASHINGTON NOW WANTS
THE HOPPED OUT OF THE ELECTION
ALL TOGETHER.
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY. ONE
THING SHE SAID.
WE ALL HAD CONSENSUS ON THEY'VE
LOST FAITH IN OUR ELECTION
PROCESS THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN IT%
ANYMORE.
THE VOTE HARVESTING THE PEOPLE
THAT AC OUT MYSTERY COLLECTING
VOTES FROM.
ALMOST PEOPLE AND SO FORTH YOUR
VOTER REGISTRATION.
I HAVE LOST FAITH IN THE
ELECTION PROCESS AND BECAUSE OF
THAT THEY'VE LOST FAITH IN THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THAT MEANS THEY'VE LOST FAITH IN
THE GOVERNMENT.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO BASICS.
I TRULY MADE OUT FROM MY HEART.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO KNOWING
WHO'S FOLDING.
NOT JUST ALLOW PEOPLE TO VOTE.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE
INTERESTED IN VOTING.
AND THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING.
FOR HOW CAN WE ALLOW SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD KIDS FOR EXAMPLE. TO
VOTE.
AND NO WATER FORTY FOUR MAY
NEVER EVEN PAID A DOLLAR IN
TAXES.
THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYTHING.
MAYBE THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
TO DRIVE.
BUT YEAH WE'RE GONNA ALLOW THEM
TO VOTE DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
SO IF THE SAME TIME -- DO HAVE A
VESTED INTEREST IN THE
GOVERNMENT TO PAY TAXES THERE
ARE BUSINESS PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE A REAL CONCERN WHAT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
HOW CAN THEY FEEL THAT THEY HAVE?
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS LOOK OUT
FOR THEM WHEN THEY ALLOW
CHILDREN.
WHO KNOW NOTHING? TO CIRCUMVENT
THEIR VOTE.
WE NEED TO REALLY STRAIGHTEN US
OUT AND GET BACK TO BASICS.
AND NOT VOTE FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS ON END BRING THIS DOWN TO
ONE OR TWO OR THREE DAYS.
LET'S HAVE SOME VOTER ID LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE REALLY
HAVE TRUST IN THE GOVERNMENT
AGAIN.
WE'RE LOSING OUR COUNTRY PEOPLE
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY LOSE IN OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY HAVE FAITH THAT ANYMORE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TALK THANK YOU SIR.
IN THE US OPPOSITION.
HELLO I'M GWEN MYERS I LIVE IN
ROSEVILLE AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THE US.
OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERONICA
SULLIVAN FROM YOU BUT COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE L. SP.
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
QUESTION SENATOR.
I JUST MOVED THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STAR I JUST
MIGHT TRUSTY STAFF JUST HANDED
ME A NOTE SAYING.
THAT JUST ABOUT TEN MINUTES AGO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE MAYBE
IT'S FIFTEEN MINUTES AGO BY NOW
CAME OUT WITH A REPORT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ELECTION AND
INDICATED THAT FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATIONS IN THAT ELECTION
IN TOTALITY AS SAYING.
AND 91% OF THOSE FOLKS WERE
COUNTED AS AFTER THEY WERE
VERIFIED TO BE COUNTED SO IS
THAT THAT WAS IMPORTANT READ
THAT INTO THE RECORD ANYTHING
FURTHER.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED ENDING FURTHER
CENTER AMERICA -- THE LET ME
JUST URGENT I VOTE AND I'VE I'VE
HEARD SOME OF THE COMMENTS I
THINK ALL OF US WANT TO ENSURE
THAT ONLY THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
ONLY THOSE WHO ARE.
CITIZENS [inaudible]
VOTE.
BUT THE TENSION THAT EXISTS IN
TERMS OF THE CONFIDENCE IN OUR
SYSTEM.
EXISTS BETWEEN THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO BASICALLY CREATE
BARRIERS AND THOSE OF US WHO
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE ACTUALLY DO
CAST THEIR BALLOTS.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THIS THIS?
INCREASES BOTH THE LIKELIHOOD
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE TO CAST THEIR
BALLOTS I CAME.
TO ELECTORAL POLITICS -- BY
VIRTUE OF AN EVENT THAT HAPPENED
IN ORANGE COUNTY WHERE ONE PARTY
POSTED FOLKS POSING AS POLICE
OFFICERS ATTEMPTED TO STOP
LATINOS FROM VOTING.
IT IS IT IS Y EXPERIENCE THAT.
JUST AS REPORTED LAST ELECTION
THAT VOTE FRAUD IS.
INFINITESIMAL INFINITESIMAL IF
IT EXISTS AT ALL AS IS
ILLUSTRATED BY THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE NO REPORTS OF FRAUD
IN THE LAST ELECTION.
SO HAVING SAID THAT I REGION.
THANKS FOR THE CHECK
[inaudible]
CALL ROBLESS.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NUMBER EIGHT NIELSEN HERTZBERG
CRISPER GUIDE LLEVA.
STERN.
STERN HI. THREE VOTES HOLD THAT
ROLE OPEN THE NUMBER GIVE
ANOTHER MEASURE FILE NUMBER.
FIVE IS THAT THE ONE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES.
THANKS LEON.
SO -- MY SP -- MEMBERS SP FIVE
OH FIVE TO THE ROBERT
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES.
BY THE NUMBER FIVE THE NUMBER
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU -- CENTERS.
MUCH TO MY SURPRISE THE THAT THE
PROCESS OF PUTTING.
CANDIDATES PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES ON THE BALLOT.
IT HAS NOT BEEN REGULARISED IN
IN THE SENSE THAT IS ALMOST
OBJECTIVE AT THIS POINT -- SP
FIVE OH FIVE SIX TO CLARIFY THE
PROCESS FOR CANDIDATES TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY.
BALLOT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
PROVIDE STATUTORY GUIDANCE FOR
CANDIDATES TO ATTAIN.
BALLOT ACCESS AND CONSEQUENTLY
HAS LED TO SIGNIFICANT CONFUSED
AND LAWSUITS PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
FILE FORMAL PAPERWORK.
OR SUBMIT DOCUMENTATION OF THE
SECTORS STATES OFFICE TO APPEAR
ON CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY BALLOT I
UNDERSTAND SEVEN REQUIRES IS
WORKING.
TO CHANGE THAT A BIT.
SINCE THE SECTOR STATE DECIDES
WHO ARE QUOTE RECOGNIZE
CANDIDATES THROUGHOUT THE NATION
OR THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA END
QUOTE.
ANY EXCLUDED CANDIDATE
REGARDLESS OF ELIGIBILITY OR
DESIRE FOR THEIR RESPECTIVE
PARTY'S NOMINATION COULD
CHALLENGE THEIR EXCLUSION AND
COULD RESULT IN UNNECESSARY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO THE
STATE.
BY REQUIRING.
THE SUBMISSION FORM.
CANDIDATES WOULD NEED TO SHOW
THAT THERE IS SOME BASIC LEVEL
OF SUPPORT AND SERIOUSNESS WHEN
SEEKING THE HIGHEST OFFICE IN
THE COUNTRY.
CANDIDATES ARE NOT SELECTED.
BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE AS
QUOTE RECOGNIZE CANDIES AND
QUOTE.
THOSE WHO ARE NOT SELECTED STILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BY
GATHERING A RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF SIGNATURES.
AND PETITIONING TO GET ON THE
BALLOT THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
THE SECTORS STATE ALEX PADILLA A
ZERO VOTE.
ANY WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
KAREN MEMBERS AT TIFFANY MARK ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE ALEX
TO DO WE ARE IN.
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR THIS BILL TO
PROVIDE CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT A
CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS.
FOR PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES FOR
OBTAINING BALLOT ACCESS AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE VOTERS THAT THEY
HAVE SERIOUS CANDIDATES ON THE
BALLOT. FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
DRIVER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS MY ANY
OTHERS IN SPORTS.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
THERE WITH A SUSPECT
.
HELLO MY NAME IS CITY WHATEVER
ON THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
CHAIR OF HIS FREEDOM PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAD TALKED -- TO THE STAFF
ABOUT THIS BEFORE -- THEY WERE
GONNA GET BACK TO US SO
[inaudible]
THE INFORMATION DIDN'T GET IN
INTEL LATE SO.
HANDED OUT -- BASICALLY.
A PEACE FREEDOM PARTIES OPPOSE
THE BILL THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS
THAT WOULD MAKE IT HIGHLY
UNLIKELY THAT ANY OF OUR
CANDIDATES WOULD EVER BE ABLE.
TO QUALIFY FOR THE PRIMARY AND
WE THINK THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR US --
NOT GOOD FOR DEMOCRACY IS FAT
MATTER.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO CALIFANO FOR
MATCHING FUNDS WHICH IS ONE OF
THE FOUR CRITERIA THAT THEY LIST
OUT.
FIRST OF ALL DEMOCRATS AND THE
REPUBLICANS CONTROL THAT PROCESS.
LIBERTARIANS IN GREEN PARTIES
HAVE BOTH TRIED TO GET RECEIVE
MATCHING FUNDS ARE GET INTO
DEBATES THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED INTO
THE DEBATES -- END OF IT.
SO THIS WAS CHANGED A LITTLE BIT
TO ALLOW. FOR PARTIES HAVE THEIR
OWN DEBATES.
WE DO DO THAT WE HAVE OUR
DEBATES BEFORE CONVENTION
BECAUSE THE CONVENTION IS WERE
WE ACTUALLY DECIDE WHO ARE.
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIES GONNA BE.
THE PRIMARY ISSUES BASICALLY AS
A BEAUTY CONTEST SO THAT OUR
DELEGATES TO THE CONVENTION
WE'LL HAVE A GOOD IDEA.
OF WHO ARE REGISTERED RANK AND
FILE MEMBERS LIKE TO SEE IS OUR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
THE CURRENTLY THE WAY THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT IS THAT -- BASED
ON PEOPLE WHO ARE SEEKING OUR
NOMINATION WE SUBMITTED A LIST
AS SECRETARY OF STATE.
UNTIL RECENTLY THAT LIST HAS
BEEN -- SELECTED [inaudible]
AND CERTIFIED.
SO WE'RE KEPALA DEBATES THE AS
FAR AS MATCHING FUNDS I DON'T
SEE PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY.
WHICH IS THE SMALLEST PART IN
CALIFORNIA BEING ABLE TO GET --
THE MATCHING FUNDS.
FROM THE FEDERAL FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND EVEN IF WE DID WE WOULD MAKE
IT BY THE DEADLINES THAT ARE SET
IN CALIFORNIA -- CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY SO EARLY CANDIDATES
SEEKING OUR NOMINATION WILL BE
ENABLED EVEN QUALIFY FOR
PLACEMENT.
ANOTHER PARTY IN ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY OR CAUCUS.
EVEN IF THEY WERE ALLOWED TO DO
SO BY THE STATE ELECTION CODES.
TEN I GUESS.
OF FINAL COMMENT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS THAT THE CANDIDATES FROM
OTHER STATES THIS IS A MUST BE
REGISTERED. TO VOTE WITH THE
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY -- IT'S
PROBABLY ABOUT.
IT DOESN'T HAVE STATES THAT
DON'T HAVE A REGISTRATION BY
PARTY.
AND SO CANDY FROM ANY OF THOSE
STATES WOULD BE REGISTERED IN
WHATEVER PARTY -- YOUR SECOND.
IN THE CURRENT BATCH TO BE LIKE
KEEPING.
BERNIE SANDERS OFF THE BALLOT
BECAUSE HE'S NOT REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT.
HE'S AN INDEPENDENT [inaudible]
VERMONT.
ANYWAY WERE OPPOSE THE BILL --
WE THINK IT -- DOES HARM -- SOME
OF THE PARTIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT GO
DOWN [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
I AM REGISTERED WINGER WITH
BALLOT ACCESS NEWS.
THERE'S SOME FLAWS IN THE BILL
IT COULD EASILY BE IMPROVED.
THE PART ABOUT.
PRIMARY SEASON MATCHING FUNDS IS
AMBIGUOUS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ONLY TWO
PEOPLE EVEN.
QUALIFIED FOR PRIMARY SEASON
MATCHING FUNDS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF SERIOUS
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT
IT.
BECAUSE IT COMES WITH STRINGS.
YOU CAN'T SPEND.
OVER A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY
IN EACH STATE IF YOU TAKE THE
MONEY.
SO IT'S IT'S VIRTUALLY A DEAD
LETTER [inaudible]
BUT IF IT WERE [inaudible]
CLARIFIED.
YOU MEAN THE THE PERSON
QUALIFIES IF.
THEY WERE SEEN [inaudible]
THE MONEY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW. FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR ME TO TWENTY STATES.
BUT THEY DIDN'T ASK FOR IT.
MUCH OF THAT WOULD COVER LOTS OF
CANDIDATES.
AND THIS CAME UP IN OHIO IT WAS
AMBIGUOUS.
AND SO THE OHIO LEGISLATURE
AMENDED THE LAW AND THEY SAID
WELL LET ME ME WHAT WE MEAN BY
THAT IS.
THE CANDIDATE RAISED THE MONEY.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
HAVE TO ASK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR IT.
AND I WAS NOT OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL UNTIL IT WAS AMENDED THE
DEBATES PROVISION WAS
[inaudible]
SUBSTANTIALLY TOUGHENED AND THAT
MEANS SOMEBODY IS SERIOUS IS
WILLIAM WELD FORMER GOVERNOR OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
IT WAS COMMUNICATED.
AS CONCERNS TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
MIGHT BE EXCLUDED.
IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN.
TWENTY TWENTY DOESN'T WANT TO
HOLD ANY PARTY SPONSORED DEBATE.
AND THEY PROBABLY WON'T.
AS IT WON'T WANT THEM TILL JUST
AS THEY DIDN'T HOLD ANY DEBATES
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
GEORGE H. W. BUSH DIDN'T WANT TO
DEBATE ANY OTHER REPUBLICAN HE'S
RUNNING FOR REELECTION.
YOU CAN QUALIFY UNDER THE
DEBATES PROVISION AS AMENDED IT
WAS OKAY BEFORE BEFORE.
THE LIKE WILLIAM WELD IN MAYBE
GOVERNOR CASEY COULD HAVE GOT
TOGETHER AND HAD THEIR OWN
DEBATE.
THE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T BE THERE
BUT SO WHAT THEY COULD HAVE
DEBATED BUT NOW IT HAS TO BE A
PARTY SPONSORED DEBATE I WAS
VERY SORRY TO SEE THAT CHANGE.
SO WILLIAM WELD IF THERE'S NO
REPUBLICAN SPONSORED DEBATE.
AND HIS PARTY DOESN'T WANT HIM
ON THE REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY BALLOT.
ALL HE'S GOT LEFT IS THAT HE
WOULD HAVE QUALIFIED FOR THE NEW
HAMPSHIRE PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
THAT'S EASY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO SATISFY TOO AND
HE COULD ONLY SATISFY.
ONE SO I FEEL THE BILL.
IS A GOOD BILL.
THE OLD LAW WAS TOO VAGUE BUT
IT'S NOT READY TO ADVANCE YET.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MCH OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
A SCENE AND BRING IT BACK TO THE
DICE MEMBER.
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS CONCERNS [inaudible]
NINE I'LL BRING IT BACK TO YOU I
I I GUESS THE ONE THING I WOULD
JUST SAY IS.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS THE SIX
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE ON WELD --
CANDIDATE BEING PLACED YOUR
QUALIFYING TO PLACE ON A BALLAD
OR CAUCUS BALLOT AT LEAST ONE
OTHER STATE.
IN THE CURRENT ELECTION CYCLE.
SEEMS TO ALLOW THAT PATHWAY EVEN
IF IT WEREN'T THROUGH A
REPUBLICAN SPONSORED.
MMHM DEBATE BUT MAYBE WE CAN
CLARIFY I MEAN THAT AND I JUST
WAS A LITTLE FEEDBACK.
YEAH -- NUMBER DIFFERENT WAYS
YOU CAN QUALIFY -- SO FOR
EXAMPLE AS YOU MENTIONED.
DEBATE IF YOU'RE INTO THE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED DEBATE IF
YOU'RE ON THE BALLOT ANOTHER
STATE -- IF YOU IF HE IS YOU
LOOK AT THE BILL IF YOU MEET TWO
OF THE CRITERIA SO FOR EXAMPLE
YOU HAVE A CAMPAIGN INTERNET
WEBSITE.
THRESHOLD IS VERY LOW.
ALSO YOU CAN QUALIFY BY IT TO
DRESS THE ISSUE CONCERNED PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY -- ISN'T FREE
IN PARTY CANDIDATES CAN QUALIFY
FOR THE BALLOT.
IF THEY'RE NOT SELECTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE BY SIMPLY
GATHERING.
IN THE CASE OF PEACE AND FREEDOM --
PARTY SEVEN AND SIXTY EIGHT
SIGNATURES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT CAN PROBABLY BE DONE IN
SAN FRANCISCO ON A WEEKEND.
OF JUST MY VIEW.
DOES THAT ADDRESS YOUR YOUR
QUESTION YES ABSOLUTELY SO.
LIGHT CLOSE YOUR THANK YOU.
IMPORTED REGISTERED.
A YES THEY DO YES.
BUT THEY CAN BE.
I DON'T WANT TO GAUGE THE
COLLOQUY HERE BUT I WILL -- BUT
BUT THEY COULD BE REGISTERED IN
SIGNED THE PETITION THE SAME DAY.
SO THE MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- JUNCTION.
THAT'S YOUR CLOTHES -- THANK YOU
FOR THE CONVERSATION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION S TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER.
AMBER I NIELSEN HERTZBERG
HERZBERG I'D LEAVE THEM STERN.
STERN I THE STERN ONE IF YOU
WANT TO SWITCH PLACES
[inaudible]
YEAH
FIRST -- SIXTY ONE SIXTY ONE
THAT'S A LOCAL REFERENDUM WHAT
ORDER YOU WILL MEAN IS FAIR.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
OKAY WE'LL DO SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIRST [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
MEMBERS IN ABSENTIA WHO I KNOW
WILL TUNE BACK IN.
TO REVIEW THE RECORD HERE --
IMPORTANT SIMPLE.
BILL HERE TODAY WE'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
STATE [inaudible]
IN.
TELLING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
HIGH SCHOOL GETTING THEMSELVES
PREPARED TO VOTE GOING THROUGH
CIVICS AND TRAINING ABOUT
DEMOCRACY THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
A SPECTATOR SPORT BUT THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TOO LONG TO WAIT
TIL YOUNG PEOPLE GO TO COLLEGE.
ACTUALLY GIVE THEM AN EQUITY
STAKE IN DEMOCRACY SO THE PRE
REGISTRATION EFFORTS IN THIS
STATE WHICH STARTED WITH THE
BILL FROM CENTER JACKSON HAVE
BEEN.
QUITE SUCCESSFUL WE HAD OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS PRE
REGISTER SINCE THE LAW CAME INTO
EFFECT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN HOWEVER
THE BILL TODAY.
TRYING TO SOLVE ONE TECHNICAL
ISSUE THAT ACTUALLY HAS TO DO
WITH AN AGE THRESHOLD BUT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT A DMV FORM.
WHEN YOU'RE FIFTEEN AND A HALF
AND YOU CAN QUALIFY FOR A
LEARNER'S PERMIT YOU FILL IT A
DL?
FORTY FOUR AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
THAT TRIGGERS A PROCESS TO
ACTUALLY ENTER YOU INTO THE
SYSTEM THEN GET PRE REGISTERED --
BY THE STATE -- HOWEVER WHEN YOU
RETURN WHEN YOU'RE SIXTEEN OR
SEVENTEEN IF YOU ACTUALLY WANTED
TO GET THAT DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU
MAY HAVE ALREADY FILLED OUT THAT
FORM ANSWER TO MISS THE MOMENT.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO SORT OF
PROVIDE A TECHNICAL FIX WE THINK
AROUND THIS THIS PARTICULAR FORM
BUT ALSO TELL -- EVERY YOU KNOW
HALF THE SOPHOMORE CLASS IS NOT
ABLE TO RE REGISTER TO VOTE AND
HALF IS WE THINK THAT'S
ARBITRARY AND YOU KNOW THE MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE WE CAN GETTING
GAUGE TO VOTE AND I DO THINK --
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE MAYBE NOT
SIXTEEN BUT I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT -- THEY DO PAY TAXES
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT TURNS OUT
I SURE DID AS A YOUNG PERSON SO --
I'M ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THIS BILL
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
[inaudible]
YES ALLIES [inaudible]
YES.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS YES SIR
YES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TURNER MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY -- SHAMANS ALONG
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARIES DAY
ALEX BUT THE YEAH.
I'M WE SUPPORT AS B. SEVEN TWO
SEVEN IF THIS MEASURE WOULD
PERMIT PRE REGISTRATION -- TO
THOUSANDS OF ELIGIBLE YOU
THOUGHT MY OTHER RACE GO I
NOTICED -- AND FIFTEEN YOU'RE
CURRENTLY FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS LIKE
THE SENATOR I MENTIONED ARE NOT
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE DMV DOES NOT PRE
REGISTER --DRIVERS WITH THAT
PERMITS.
WITH LEARNER'S PERMITS -- I'D
LIKE TO THINK SENATOR STERN FOR
AUTHORING SESSION FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARJUN I'VE THANK YOU.
DURAS THE RIVER IS A CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT AND IF IT'S AMANDA
DOWN TO FIFTEEN THAT WOULD MAKE
EVEN MORE SENSE BECAUSE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A HALF YEAR WHEN
YOU'RE READY JUST PRE
REGISTERING KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
THEY'RE READING IT ON THE
EVERYONE KNOWS THE DMV
[inaudible]
YEAH SO.
THANK YOU YEP RESPECT AS RAPPER
[inaudible]
YES I YOU MOVE I NEED TO MOVE.
THE TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
LABOR.
TURN.
I STERN HI.
THANK YOU BUSTED.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
YES.
SB SIX EIGHTY ONE IS.
TRYING TO ESTABLISH SOME PARITY
WITH SEVERAL OTHER REFORMS WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN IN THE LEGISLATURE --
STARTING A WAYS BACK WITH A BILL
FROM SENATOR STEINBERG THAT
ALLOWED THE LEGISLATURE. TO TAKE
A LOOK AT A BALLOT INITIATIVES
THAT ARE BEING QUALIFIED AND
GIVE THE PROPONENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO REMOVE THAT
MEASURE -- OR ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
TO IT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS STILL AT THE
CORE OF DEMOCRACY IN THIS STATE
AND IT'S STILL HELD DEAR BY MANY
VOTERS BUT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THAT FOLKS
DON'T GET LOCKED INTO IDEAS THAT
MAY HAVE SOUNDED LIKE A GOOD
IDEA.
AT THE TIME AND THEN WHEN MORE
FACTS COME TO LIGHT IN THE
PROCESS PLAYS OUT.
WE NEED TO MAKE CHANGES OR EVEN
REMOVE THAT MEASURE ALL TOGETHER
A BILL WE MOVE LAST YEAR --
WOULD HAVE A THINGS AT ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE WOULD ALLOW THE
REMOVAL OF INITIATIVES -- AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- BUT WE DIDN'T DO
SURE AS TRY
NOT JUST FOR INITIATIVES BUT FOR
ALSO FOR REFERENDUM TO ALLOW
LOCAL MEASURES TO BE WITHDRAWN
AND HOPEFULLY AVOID A BIG COSTLY
FIGHT -- OVER COMPORT CONFUSING
BALLOT WE'VE GOT COMPETING
MEASURES THAT REALLY DON'T MAKE
SENSE TO VOTERS SO WE THINK IS
GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE
HOPEFULLY SAVE SOME COST TO
TAXPAYERS AND KEEP VOTERS A
LITTLE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT IS
THEY'RE VOTING ON MISTER
CHAIRMAN TERRY BRENNAN ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA WE SPONSORED.
LAST YEAR'S BILL WHICH BROUGHT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT PROCESS IN
LINE WITH THE STATE PROCESS
RELATIVE TO WITHDRAWING
INITIATIVES -- GENIUS THAT IT
WAS WE ADDED TO THE REFERENDUM
AND THIS YEAR WE'RE FIXING THAT
AS WELL AS APPLYING IT -- CITIES
WHO NEED DIRECT AUTHORIZATION TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS AS WELL SO
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORTED.
BIGGEST RUN.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
REMEMBERS FROST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
BUSY DAY.
DORA'S THE HUMAN VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT MAKES
SENSE EFFICIENCY POURTANT BILL.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE OPPOSE.
THE NEW OPPOSITION SENATOR LIKE
CLOSE YOUR FAST RIVAL ALL RIGHT.
MA'AM SECTOR CALL THE ROLL --
MOVE THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL FINANCE COMMITTEE
NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN HERTZBERG
FLAVOR STERN STERN I OF WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ON A FEW
OTHER BILLS IF ANYONE IS WITHIN
EARSHOT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
COMMITTEE DOWN WE HAVE NO MORE
BILLS TO BE HEARD THIS MORNING.
SO I WOULD URGE -- ANY ONE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED TO THE
ROLE TO COME DOWN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
ALL RIGHT -- MEDICINE TREE WITH
WHAT.
BILLS WE NEED THE OPEN WHICH ARE
STILL.
ITEM ONE ITEM -- ONE SP FORTY
SEVEN BUT I'M SICK TO YOU CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
EYES WILL AND NO ONE KNOWS WHAT
THE CHAIR VOTING EYEING STERN.
STERN I FOUR DOOR THAT WAS WHICH
THAT WAS THAT WAS AN AMBER.
THE THAT WAS -- SEVEN ROUNDS AS
BE FORTY SEVEN YES.
ITEM NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP.
ONE THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THIS SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE CRIME VOTERS
THREE EYES AND NO ONE KNOWS WHAT
THE CHAIR VOTING I STERN.
SERVICES.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP
[inaudible]
ONE THIRTY NINE STERN I ZERO IS.
IN ITEM NUMBER SIX SP FIVE
ELEVEN BY SENATOR MORLOCK.
MADAME SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE CURRENT
LOTUS THREE EYES NO NOSE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING EYEING STERN
[inaudible]
HI.
NEXT IS -- SEVEN REQUIRES GO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP.
FIVE TWENTY THREE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT LOTUS THREE
EYES NO NOSE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING EYES STERN.
STERN HI.
BUT THE NICEST CONSENT -- NEXT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY.
SB SIX SIX FOUR ALLEN MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSENT ITEM.
CREDIBLE IS THREE EYES NO NOSE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NICE STERN.
STERN I ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN HERE JUST
FOR A FEW MORE MOMENTS -- CENTER
STERN THANK YOU.
SEE IN A LITTLE WHILE.
MORE.
RECENTLY THE YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE VOTE
.
ITEM NUMBER.
NINE ITEM NUMBER NINE NUMBER.
THOUGH THE YOU'RE LUCKY IT'S A
MISSED IT'S A CENTER STERN BILL.
SO -- INSIDE OVERNIGHT SB SIX
EIGHTY ONE BY SENATORS STERN
MOTION IS TO PASS TO GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT IS -- ITEM
OVER TEN SENATOR STERN'S BILL SB.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MINUTE TO SEND
APPROPRIATIONS HERTZBERG.
HURTS BERG I ALL RIGHT -- COMMIT